welcome March 29th happy uh
Wednesday to you join here today by
Bryce Hall
internet bad boy x x internet back are
you an ex bad boy yeah you're reformed
bad boy yes where did you become
reformed
um I'd say like over a year ago was it
the mushroom trip
I did talk about that a little bit Yeah
the mushrooms reformed you yeah mushroom
turned you from a bad boy into a good
boy
yeah I would say that
okay good we like that thanks guys thank
you would you say that being a good boy
is more boring no
I'd say like it's it's uh
less hate which is which is fun you're
getting less hate yeah and we're able to
sit here together which is nice yeah I
know did you either surprisingly nicer
than I thought you would be thanks and
you too I mean I think I'm a nice person
yeah I feel like you put up like this
this Persona that like you're just a
douche very straightforward it's my
intentional I want the world to know
that I'm a giant dude no I think um
I think the people who I talk about
I understand why they would dislike me
you know I was going back and watching
the clip when I was talking about you
I'm also reformed uh bad boy if you
might even look at us yeah look at us
I've been reformed maturity Hallelujah
yeah uh I went back and talked well
looking when the first time I talked
about you and Frenemies and I was like
dude I was really a [__] being a
little bit
being a little kind of a douche but like
you said it's just like the the stuff
that I was putting out there it made me
look way worse than I actually was right
yeah well I will say you're 23 right
yeah you know looking over kind of your
everything you've been through I gotta
say you've been through a lot of [__]
for a young man I lived a life yeah
that's fact yeah
uh before we get into that we were watch
we were talking when you arrived about
our mutual friend Ryan Kavanaugh yeah
my bestie your bestie thank you my
factual bestie your anime is he your
bestie I would say he's one of my closer
friends yeah that's so interesting
because to me he's like
he's like
I'm trying to I put this accurately he's
like the worst dude he's like sub such a
big piece of [__] so the thing is about
Ryan Kavanaugh is yeah if you are
friends with Ryan Cavanaugh he will
treat you like family and the best that
he could possibly treat another guy he's
got to hold on your enemies with Ryan
Kavanaugh he will drag you down through
mud well he hasn't dragged [__] I'll
tell you what I think he regrets of her
[__] hearing my name
he's tried
um but so that's interesting and also
you mentioned that Brad the bull is your
manager that is so weird that you call
him that but I'll tell you what he's
gonna get an ego for that well I'll tell
you why and I think you'll like it I
asked you
if uh Ryan Kavanaugh had ever asked you
to [__] his wife oh he's divorced now
Brad the Bull's dating his ex right
um Ryan and Jess I I have no idea what's
wrong I know everything but like I got
all the right Kevin on Gossip yeah it's
crazy I don't even know what the beef is
or anything about it that's fun so I
want to explain it to you and obviously
you're close with him so I'm not I'm not
trying to ruin your life I'm definitely
not saying don't work with him and not
that you would listen to me because you
should work with him he's great he's
great for you but um
I would think it'd be funny to explain
our our mutual best I I will not give my
input or I will give my input you can I
just wanna I just want to hear what
happened yeah yeah yeah I have no idea
so first of all Brad the bull we love
Brad the bull he's he's our boy what
happened was um well he was married to
this girl I don't know her name and then
all of a sudden she started posting all
these pictures with Brad the bull this
jacked [__] like
apparently and then we saw pictures of
them all in bed together
and we're like yo I think Brad the bull
in a custom relationship the Bull's the
one that you know has sex with the wife
and then Ryan Cavanaugh uh who's the
[__] cocky
is the one that masturbates in the
corner and cries
I I can tell you from personal
experience that that uh Ryan and Jess
are not together and Brad and Ryan are
best friends they're best friends yeah
right and that happens a lot when when
the bull relationship there's a mutual
respect well but there's no there's no
cucking I I would assume he left him for
Brad I think I don't think it was like
that at all no he actually asked her
asked him permission
because they were friends
that's but isn't that crazy his they
were friends
and then all of a sudden he's like yo
can I [__] can I [__] your wife I don't
think he asked like that I think does it
mean I take her hand can I take her hand
and put it on my [__]
is that what the sound effects
by the way uh just uh just before I get
too deep in the cabinet you got this
drink coming out I wanna uh the blackout
yeah I'm gonna hit this for you really
you're gonna you're gonna test it live
you can be honest I don't even I don't
even like how can it taste bad right
is it carbonated no
big mistake
it's carbonated it's like a little bit
oh it's good it's good I like the name
blackout trademarks blackout that's
that's pretty sick no challenges yeah
interesting did you have to buy it uh no
I there was already somebody that was
working on it and I partnered up with
them through Dana White which is Dana
White okay well connected
um this is great it says jeric
responsibly at right next to the title
blackout seems to be in some kind of
contradiction I wonder how many college
kids were going to kill of on this one I
mean that's the demo that we want yeah
cheers let the bodies hit the floor
I'll drink it with you hmm
it is very good thank you and only 100
calories that's nice I'll definitely
black out on that I'll send you a
package okay thank you yeah so um
but that is interesting to know so they
were friends Ryan and his wife
apparently broke up and then Brad the
bull stepped in
and here I can definitely could call him
Brad the bull that is so oh and then you
said he wanted to meet me
um so then we tried calling him yeah I
would I would like definitely I think
he's seen the clips obviously because
you guys have her beef or whatever with
right
um but he just wanted to like
say like what's up I don't know I'd love
to say what's up I think he's awesome I
have no problem with Brad yeah I think
you and Ryan just by the small
interactions that I had with you and the
long interactions that I had with Ryan
if you guys like got through your
differences I feel like you guys would
be really good friends it's on him which
is he's the one suing me he's laughing
over there but like you guys are very
similar in certain ways don't say that
nothing like him
take it back take that back right
[__] now
um yeah we have a sound bite
specifically for Brad the bull I hear
the yeah
yeah but if you want to create if you
want to cut if you want to call him and
FaceTime him call Brad yeah Brad the
ball because he's a celebrity here
and he manages you and you're his only
client yeah that's pretty cool that
means you have a lot of trust in him oh
yeah
let's see if he answers that's crazy
that you're in so deep with the
Kavanaugh Camp I'll see if he answers
hopefully he answers would be like a bad
manager thing to do
dude this is definitely going against
him you answer the [__] phone price
calls
he's actually oh you're his only client
he's always on his phone too so it like
doesn't make sense that he's not
answering right now
yo Brad just dropping the ball brother
he's [__] he's probably [__] uh
she's in South Africa right now
he's like hold on uh hey Ryan can you
get that Ryan who is it
we're not together
well I'm glad that actually I have to
say I when I announced that you're
coming on the show I thought Ryan might
call you and tell you not to go and I
have to say I'm impressed that he did it
yeah no he really didn't that's cool I
appreciate that
yes so I'll tell you kind of just give
you a crash course
uh we he did this boxing event
um
thought it was years ago now this has
been going on
he did the it was some kind of trailer
boxing event
which one
do we have which one was it do you guys
remember which one oh the Jake Paul the
Jake Paul versus
oh [__] and literally we just we watched
a clip of it on the show reacting to it
like many people on the internet do
and then um
he sued me for copyright infringement
were you watching it live no these were
just Clips yeah the fight was over for
for several days huh the pay-per-view
was over the fight was over we actually
only watched like
less I think it and I I'm I think it's
been so long now less than 30 seconds of
it and he sued me for copyright
infringement we think it may have been
motivated by Jake right
do you and Jake have problems
I think at the time he may have not been
happy with me
Paul won the bout yeah okay so
yeah um the fight was one minute 59
seconds right
so you probably watched the whole fight
I don't think we did I don't think we
did actually or just the actual knockout
we watched the actual knockout yeah
and so he sued me for copper
infringement I was like who the [__] is
this guy
and we looked into cav-cav a little bit
he owns triller
which frankly is such a shitty app I
don't believe you're even posting to it
as a best friend he he uh that's just
like one of the 50 things that he is
he's got his hands and all kinds of but
it was like triller was was popular in
gaining a lot of popularity when tick
tocks first
um rumors of right of it being deleted
in 2020 and I mean now there's more
rumors that tick tock's gonna be deleted
again so I mean it might he might get
that it's the closest thing to tick tock
other than you know the reels and
spotlights and all them like that's man
15 cent yeah the when was this posted
March 17th have you well having my name
post since then the trailer well I mean
look at that that's with 50 Cent that
was the next one
ever
I told him I was like I don't want to do
this man
oh funny that's funny yeah yeah but you
haven't posted today yeah no I don't I
don't really post on like anything other
than um
Tick Tock Snapchat right now Instagram
Twitter
I don't even really post on uh Instagram
that much
yes so anyway he so then we were like yo
look at the trailer this app sucks it
was flipped for a whole day he sued me
for saying it's flipped things flipped
so Noah back one day the app was flipped
what does that mean it it meant that
when you moved the camera left the
screen went right or something right is
something very odd about the way it was
Noah back made this video saying Trilla
your thing is flipped so now we play
that sound all the time and he pseudos
for that
wait play the audio yo trailer my
thing's flipped
what was that on that was on trailer
Noah Beck uh presumably was being paid
here I'll show you the original one like
live it was no it was a trailer he
posted this video yo this dude was like
I don't give a [__] about trailer I'm
gonna post this [__]
my thing's flipped
my camera's like flipped around right
now but look
I'm I'm trying to uh it's so awkward hey
guys like look it's when I put it this
way
should I head off yeah so we're like
dude Ryan you're true your app is
[__] flipped as hell what account was
that hard times eight that was just a
re-upload oh yeah I think I think um
Bryce probably erased his account
because they stopped paying him oh Noah
Noah sorry Noah I'm Bryce yeah sorry
that's my bad you're sitting right in
front of me
and then um
Let's see we uh a lot listen a lot we
encouraged a lot of our audience to
leave honest reviews about the app
which they did and obviously the app is
flipped they lied about Kevin Hart being
on it this man wrote in the description
of trilly he said featuring celebrities
like Kevin Hart would it shock and
surprise you if Kevin Hart didn't even
have a [__] account on trailer
I have no idea you asked for this you
asked for the background on this one boy
and so um anyway he sued us for that he
soon we have copper infringement so how
many law experience how many lawsuits
are on you right now is yes so and then
he sued me for defamation for some
really silly [__] reading the headline
of an article that said
variety wrote an article that said
Ryan Kavanaugh accused of running a
Ponzi scheme by his ex-partner
which was retracted but he's suing me
for reading the headline for defamation
so there's that and then also he tried
to take down one of our websites
which is uh does Ryan Kavanaugh look
like Harvey Weinstein have you seen that
I I actually I think I saw that in one
of the Articles okay cool yeah so if you
type his name Ryan Kavanaugh which I
encourage everyone to do
uh it's the second result which
obviously Google's decided is very
relevant for his name
um the public is confused
they are not the same person but they
have a lot of similarities for example
we put this helpful graph together
that's I mean it's like this is very
trollish but they don't look alike well
well thanks to me I mean it's easy to
say that now but thanks to my efforts uh
you can say that with the confidence
um let's see Noah back my thing was slip
here is uh here they have appeared
together
uh so it's hard you hear it's Ryan came
out kissing Harvey Weinstein on the head
incidentally
did you know that he all right did you
know he's got DUI's like a few DUIs
actually
uh let's see
I'm probation and he actually was
arrested for drunk driving driving while
on probation this one's crazy lying
under oath
uh when relativity so essentially
essentially like your guys's beef is
because you'll go into detail and and
look up a bunch of stuff and then air it
out to your viewers and he doesn't like
that yeah we're just doing journalism
yeah but you know the media is just such
[__] sometimes
yeah but I'm not the media I'm like uh
I'm like a journalist you're a
journalist I'm like dedicated
yeah but he started it dude he started
it man and then so but anyway he like
did you know that he falsely accused his
ex-president from relativity media of
being uh sexually uh harassing was it
sexual harass he he falsified the
document that's why we call him Cav
because they're forensic uh analysis on
the document that he falsified and the
last person to edit was cav-cav so
that's why we call him kavkov thank you
Pontius scheme I explained that he
sniffed his babysitter for 175. I think
you guys should have a conversation he's
threatened critics he sent me this
message bro he sent me a DM I think you
guys should talk
I think you guys would would actually
like each other okay well he can start
by dropping the [__] 20 lawsuits
against me
uh
you want to read this it's pretty wild
I'll read it to you he says Ethan I am
not sure why you've decided to take it
upon yourself in your show to malign
attack and slander and defame me I do
not know you I also don't know why
you're spending thousands of dollars on
dummy accounts post fake statements
about me on my Instagram and tens of
thousands uh to of fake comments to the
app store for uh trailer that's all that
is just defamatory I'll have you know
where's that you dedicate an entire show
of yours reading your own fake reviews
that is a lie malicious lie while I'm
using a slightly annoying at best I
would advise you to stop and mitigate
your damage now your toy podcast he said
seems fun and all but this is real
business with real consequences and
you're causing real damage clearly you
are very unhappy and Disturbed humid
that take it upon yourself to attack
someone you don't know with false and
misleading information especially to
spend tens of thousands of dollars on it
but it must stop you have been warned
and I will not be threatened in the line
stand by uh and stand by idly govern
yourself accordingly
dude thinks he's a super villain
here's a book he's got a great
vocabulary all right he's a good author
I get it yeah there's one more thing and
that is Ryan Cavanaugh is a force of
nature that's it and we will move on but
thanks for sitting also he he pledged a
million dollars to Habitat for Humanity
and he never gave him the money
thank you
sounds
I have an amazing announcement but they
donated a million bucks because of all
your hearts he never gave him the money
I know I know for a fact Ryan Kavanaugh
does a lot of stuff for charity yeah
just not them I don't know what charity
that is but thank you for sitting
through that I didn't bring you here for
the yeah now I mean I am doing that I
understand now like the thing is we have
deep beef yeah you guys definitely go
back and forth that's why I figured he
would be like yo price don't go on no no
no no no he actually did not even
mention it there you go so he's got some
class after all
also he says he wants to have sex with
14 year old Natalie Portman play it
stop dude we don't even need a
relationship with a 40 year old Natalie
apartment we don't I'm just saying all
right well let's anyway I'm not here to
uh
to uh got you with Kavanaugh stuff so
tell me about um
we ran into each other at Laguna Beach
we did so that was interesting I was
there for a charity football game
charity football game and um with a
bunch of NFL players oh really yeah I
can't imagine that they were easily uh I
definitely wasn't good yeah it doesn't
seem like a very fair uh lineup I know
it was like all NFL X quarterbacks
current quarterbacks Josh Allen was
there
um Aaron Rodgers he's like a bunch of
people and um did you what uh charity
were you guys raising for each team
represented a different charity um Okay
cool so it was pretty sick so I was
there with Ela uh and my dogs and we
were there just getting away because my
wife's about to get pregnant with our
third baby so we were just taking like a
little bit of a weekend off and it was
nice running into you I was pleasantly
surprised you were very nice very uh you
were formed you've been reformed and um
and it's nice that we got to connect and
get you on we were trying to get you on
the show what like a year ago yeah yeah
yeah and so
you told me when I met you you're like
yo I've been vaccinated now so I can
come in
Ryan Kavanaugh is calling me
let's go I don't think I should answer
this should I let's [__] God
right yeah
I'm live
turn up his mic yeah
yeah
I'll call you back
you want to step away call him
does he not know I don't think he even
oh that's just sucks I don't think he
knows I'm live right now oh okay yeah
that's fun
that's the closest I've ever had to
talking to him that's about the little
tingle hearing it was like I was kind of
getting like nervous I was like what is
this
wait should we have a should we have a
um conference call right now
I think I think you guys should have a
conversation
I'm open to it
man imagine it's live on the air like
this
that would be [__] good content boy
yeah I feel like I feel like you guys
could either make up or it just gets
really bad really fast and then I'm in
an awkward situation where I'm just
sitting in the middle of it we'll become
besties we're like we don't need you
anymore
you'll be like I'll be like Brad the
ball to your
do you would you text and be like yo
let's have a let's hash this out right
now should I text him and just be like
yo I'm live with Ethan let's hash this
up all right Brad just called me
they're all okay okay
I'll I'll call Brad real bad this is
great because I can't emphasize how deep
lore this is yeah we're live right now
Brad the bull the legend the stallion
he looked pissed dude no they were they
keep playing the the bull sound and I'm
like this guy's gonna get an ego
but now we do we uh we we talked about
it it was very very short
um I just got a understanding of the
beef and now we're done yeah we're
moving on Brad
subject matter I don't like okay
thanks Brad
I heard hey Brad
thanks for taking care of her bro stop
stop
it's not like that
it's like it's it's the it's the sly
it's the little slight shade I don't
know but all right
base
can't do that to Brad you I thought he'd
be cool well I gotta say when he saw me
he was like he was like oh [__] no not
that guy he's like I don't I don't want
to be involved in it oh [__]
oh [__] that's fine oh [__] that's
that's better than I could but yeah that
is my manager Brad he seems like a good
guy again I love Brad I got no problem
with our boy Brad ever found it for Brad
yeah Brad is Brad is a good guy yeah
he's taking care of me yeah but so is
Ryan
that's important I want people it's
important
so anyway we were we were talking about
the oh are you would you text him and
say let's just kind of carm's gone hash
this out the Kafka
I mean it's up to him he says no we move
on you know what I mean and of course
you don't have to we can move on too to
be honest I don't even want to be in
that awkward scenario yeah that's fine
we can move on I can I can do that after
I leave the podcast I hope I don't get
you in trouble though yeah hopefully
yeah too much wine sorry well you're his
only client what's he gonna do fire you
be unemployed Brad yeah oh Brad's a very
successful real estate guy so I mean
you fire you you think I don't think I
think we're just more friends than
anything we're just friends that do
business yeah you guys are dogs yeah
so anyway
uh where were we we were talking about I
ran into oh yeah you said um the last
time I invited you on the show uh I
guess you weren't vaccinated but now you
are vaccinated not that I I didn't check
it but
are you not as good are you were you
like against vaccinations were you no no
it was just um it was the timing of
everything it was um because it was so
new
um and I just I just didn't have the
time to like go in multiple shots that's
fair yeah yeah busy guy mm-hmm
kind of hard to move past all the
Kavanaugh stuff you need like a minute
to decompress it's like after all that I
was at 10. I can't believe I just came
face to face with Brad the bull I stared
him down like a matrador what is it
called the [__] Spanish bullfighters
Matador yeah I'd stare him down like a
matador he snarled and looked at me I
saw red in his eyes it was the greatest
opponent I'd ever faced down
[Music]
maybe here let me find something funny
we can watch maybe to break just break
the tension a little bit
you know are you cool with Austin
McBroom did you guys ever make it up or
you still hate him I hate him I think
yeah I know I've seen like a lot of
Clips yeah thank you yeah I just think
I mean it's just I think drama in
general now is just like complete
[__] and I think it's a waste of
time well he ripped you off yeah he did
and he attempted to rip off like every
single fighter on the card which is like
pretty shitty that's not drama if it
wasn't intentional I do apologize but
like
he went in there promised an amount for
every single person to go train take
time off of their actual careers for
three months and only focus on one thing
for most of us not to even get paid
which which sucks he like he ripped off
the artists that performed he ripped off
um the the investors he ripped off the
fighters he ripped off everybody and I'm
surprised that he's uh actually still
getting opportunities that's what it's
blowing my [__] mind he went out and
didn't have another boxing event yeah he
did and I mean it did absolutely
terrible well I'm not surprised who the
[__] would work with him after that I
mean it was Social Clubs it was his
company but that time he didn't have
investors I'm assuming
so did you ever get and he promised you
five million right yeah that's a pretty
fat payday yeah did you get any of that
uh I got I got some but we're a small
amount of it or like a decent chunk I
mean I got a small amount compared to
the five million but I mean I still got
something which is nice and then um
we're still working on it legally to get
the full amount okay so so that's right
that's why I'm still okay with like
social gloves doing their thing yeah
please make money yeah just just make
money so I can get paid you know okay
that's interesting yeah he's such a [__]
he's fighting again
um in like two weeks really yeah didn't
he just get his ass beat by someone yeah
Gib and he's fighting Gibb again wow
he's didn't dude okay good for him he's
hustling yeah he's doing like those
those boxing matches what did you see
actually I've been meaning to watch this
video it could be fun to watch it
together he put out a video saying um
that he was done I saw that that he only
lost because he got covered
like out of nowhere he also admitted
that he he injected himself before the
fight injected with what
um IVs which is against like fighting is
it you can't take an IV no not not
before a fight because it's like you can
I don't know what's in it it's an
enhancer right so yeah he admitted to
that on video which is crazy
um well apparently it's not deterring
anyone a Gib from fighting him again I
mean did and it's like he's pulling the
the hey I coughed right before my fight
type vibes
yeah there was there was a clip of him
being like um in the best shape I've
ever been I just I just gotta admit like
yeah I got my ass kicked and I have no
excuses for it other than my nerves this
man made a whole ass documentary like 20
20 minutes yeah trying to explain why
his ass got beat because he had covered
but there that is
yeah okay well I hope you get paid from
him yeah it'd be nice you know
oh here let me open it here's where he
says he has covid by the way I don't
think you're supposed to fight when you
have kovid either genius
pretty sure you just admitted to like a
crime yeah he's like I walked into a
huge Auditorium
I think it got passed because there was
nobody in the actual Stadium there's
nobody there yeah yeah here's when he
says uh he's covered
okay come on not keemstar
[Music]
okay to share what I experienced that
night with you guys
all right everybody everybody out
it's all edited
that's true that was one hell of a fight
okay you're one hell of a fighter you
deserve that win and I wish you the best
of luck that being said I would have
definitely beat his ass if I wasn't sick
he's like you're a good fighter you
deserve that win but the only reason I
lost is because yeah yeah yeah I would
have beat your ass so I feel like
majority of people who experienced or
would have experienced what I
experienced at night would have shared
this story immediately definitely the
old Austin would have shared this the
night after the fight dude what the
[__] douche
yo anyone else would have wouldn't be
able to hold this I waited I waited six
months to say this to tell you all that
oh yeah guys I forgot to mention in my
fight with Austin I also had coven right
so now that's that's actually the only
reason I lost it's dope that you waited
this long to tell us I had to wait two
years before I disclose this information
but yeah I had coveted during my fight
and that's the only reason I lost this
is awesome actually
Umi want to wait until the time was
right and I also didn't want to take
anything away from Gibb that night so
now I'm about to share something with
you guys that nobody knows besides my
family where did this fight take place
I think sofa it was like a massive way
sofa uh downtown okay so because in La
would they have we have super strict or
the Staple Center was it the Staple
Center or was it Sofi I remember it was
it was in LA though yeah because they LA
City has really strict covet rules so
there's no way this dude didn't break
the law
again yeah this was also six months ago
right
on my team
I'ma try my best to narrate the day of
the fight and
you know I was saying you've been
through a lot uh in your life where
where is it that you grew up where are
you from Maryland Maryland yeah
dangerous part of Maryland uh like 20
minutes from it 20 minutes it's a
dangerous day right or some parts are
dangerous some parts it has its nice
areas though yeah there's like really
nice areas of Maryland uh I was blessed
to be growing up in the Ellicott City
Columbia area
um but yeah there's bad parts of
Maryland too yeah but that's with every
state and you grew up uh in a single
parent uh house is that right
shout out Mama yeah yeah what what's the
story with your dad when did he uh did
he leave before you were born or after I
was two wow two-ish yeah
that's hard yeah but my mom did great
ish she raised a guy like me well it's
not easy to raise us you know as I have
kids now I can only I don't know how
single parents do it and this is like a
miracle
you stressed her out so much as a kid
too so I like feel like even worse when
I'm now an adult and I understood
uh do you remember your dad leaving I
don't know he was pretty young I
actually
um had no idea even what he looked like
until my mom sent me a recent photo of
them and I didn't get any genetics any
genetics from him yeah
but he's not pretty oh he's not he's not
a good looking guy yeah okay your dad is
ugly yeah already here Dad loser
and um
is he still alive has he tried to reach
it yeah uh he has tried
um to reach out
like since your success or do you think
it's because you're successful or
because he wants to connect with his
sons definitely because of success he
that my mom I mean obviously I have no
idea who he is as a person but like my
mom has told me he's a mooch he was like
using my mom for what she had my mom's
like making good money as a single mom
like even as a woman she's making great
money especially living in Maryland now
she lives in Florida but
um he just never had like a stable job a
stable income
he was always just relying on her
so were they ever married or no my mom
and dad were not married but my mom was
married to a guy before my dad I see
yeah you have any siblings uh seven half
brothers seven half or so
so my dad has six other holy [__] kids
that dude has been busy yeah and he and
they all start with BR really all the
kids start with BR and they're all boys
whoa what are what other BR names are
there Brian is like Brandon Brandon
um Bryce I don't know any of the other
ones but I remember my mom telling me
all their names and they all start with
BR that's [__] wild so he doesn't
really have like a different
not very creative yeah he's not really
creative with the name do you know your
your half siblings I know one of them
which is Brandon Brandon yeah he's like
the closest to my age and did he abandon
kind of all of his kids yeah
wow what a [__] piece of [__] right
what's it like just let let uh I think
uh one of the moms has four kids
man so there's three or four different
moms how many different moms are there I
think there's three or four and do the
moms know each other
um
I think my mom talked to Brandon's mom
but how'd you guys meet me and Brandon
yeah he lives in Maryland so we were
kind of just
we're still close with my dad's family
which is weird Okay but so you found out
I met I met Brandon through my dad's
family
and we kind of like are similar in
certain ways like we lift weights you
know that is weird so you're close with
your dad's family what like his uh his
sister siblings his sister so like his
aunt or my aunt I mean whoa
and what does he do is he just like a
bum like what is he up to he's in and
out of jail all the time he's like such
a
idiot
mainly for abuse
really yeah
wow so how was it kind of growing up
with just your mom did you have maybe
like I see you we call you the bad boy
we say that kind of like jokingly but
you do get into fights and stuff a lot
and have maybe I don't know if it's fair
to say like maybe
are angry
at the world kind of I just I was
bullied my entire life growing up really
and I didn't realize it was unnatural to
have only a mom in my household until
like kids at school were like making fun
of me for it that way they were bullying
you no I mean well one of the reasons
but that's what I'm saying do kids are
so [__] weird they're so weird one
parent Heaven Loser yeah you don't have
a dad loser like you're like l no no dad
no but um
that was one of the reasons I was also
overweight as a kid so like my entire
life
um I was just bullied stepped on um
and it clicked in high school like
halfway through High School
uh that I just was tired of it I was I
took steroids oh that helped you that
that was the one that like passed me if
you stop don't you lose the weight no
not dude that's you lose the initial
push but it's super easy to get back up
to it naturally really it's not natural
anymore sarms is used to bulk up and
increase strength but without some of
the negative side effects of steroids
disarms work by binding to Andrew and
androgen receptors and muscles and Bones
there's also like six different types
muscle mass and strength increase fire
yeah did you get it was it like a black
market thing
um I got it through one of my trainers
oh that's what's up trainers always have
[__] yeah trainers and I was like hey
how are you getting so big he's like oh
I have this little sauce I like and is
it like an injection no it was pill form
oral oh see that's even better yeah
because most steroids are injected right
in your butt I don't like all that I'm
scared of needles that's why I haven't
like hopped on like the real stuff so
you only took it for six months and you
like six weeks I mean six weeks and
you're like boom yeah
and what happens if I take sarms you
don't want to take Sirens you can if you
like just inject I didn't realize I
guess when you look at someone who's
like super jacked it's fairly easy to
tell if they're on steroids oh yeah
because they're like there's like a
normal body
and then there's Bradley Martin Bradley
Martin that man is on steroids right
that man is massive
a human can you not look like that
natural no okay
you can't you can't look like that even
close to that natural because I'm
wondering like what's the possible limit
you can do off but anyway the point is I
think it's like super [__] common
there's there's like lifetime natural
bodybuilders but you'll even see them
they look nothing like that nothing like
that that's like a that is a bikini
looks like Hulk like literally Hulk that
is a bear as a man yeah even well even
Hassan my friend and Coho says he's just
straight up like yeah I want to take
steroids he's like I just want to look
[__] jacked like that he would he
would blow up he's like six foot five he
would look crazy he would get
so big this man is natural though I've
heard yeah no he's very natural
oh [__] that reminds me he said he
wanted to come back on
and talk about his natural Journey right
did we ever reach out to his people
I'm not sure honestly you send me that
weird voice note [__]
I've wanted to have a conversation with
this guy but I feel like he's just so
animated he's a character he's not a
real person
[Music]
I want to talk to Brian you know what I
mean not liver King
but uh that's let's reach out I'm gonna
make that he's like a 45 year old Jim
bro yeah that has never got out of like
the screaming of uh
of like gains muscles um
it's crazy okay interesting so let's see
oh my God that's what he used to look
like
that's what ceremy's does huh
yeah that's sick Bro
and what even I don't even know if like
Brad's open about like his his uh his
use
but
man so what is it here I'm reading about
the sarm side effects I'm just curious
it says it could lead to irregular
periods I don't believe that affects you
yeah no right
I saw like a few videos of like some
people losing vision oh [__] that yeah
so I got I got scared and immediately
hopped off just a side effects might
include blind blindness because more
than half of sarm's users experience
side effects including mood swings
decreased ball size oh I mean that's
with any it's like with any steroids did
your balls shrink yeah your balls like
tighten up they tighten up yeah like the
Skin's tight you got a tight sack yeah
like think about when you hop in like a
cold uh tub and your balls your balls
get like really small it's like that 24
7. are they still like that no once you
once you stop your body starts producing
natural testosterone again and your
natural testosterone comes from your
balls and if you're injecting stuff or
if you're taking stuff you're relying on
that testosterone so your balls aren't
really needed that's [__] interesting
some people like a tight sack I mean it
makes your strong look bigger it does
yeah because the balls look smaller Yeah
by comparison it looks bigger yeah these
are good things
kite sack tight sack big schlong
I'm feeling that may cause hair loss I
also saw yeah that's that's every
steroid steroids yeah
well that's exciting
um so you grew up
I gotta like my dad grew up in a similar
fashion he had a dad who walked out on
him when he was like five
and I know it just it affected him so
deeply for his whole life I I genuinely
feel like it's one of the most [__] up
things a person can do
in life
just to abandon their child do you have
resentment towards him do you have like
feelings at all or do you try not to
feel anything about it I try to feel
nothing about it
does that work though I mean I like I
said I never knew it was unnatural to
grow in a a single mom household right
so I I don't even know what it's like to
have a dad
so I have no feelings towards it because
I I've never experienced having a father
figure this is just like how I grew up
my normal right
do you have like a father figure that
you've kind of like sought out or looked
for in the world my mom says I did but I
I definitely don't know again I don't
know what a father figure is like like I
don't know is it someone that gives me
advice on my financials is it somebody
that he carries you know it leads me in
a in a certain direction like he then I
have a lot of those it's a you know it's
it's meant to be I think theoretically
ideally
a lot of us have shitty dads uh but you
know
um a positive male role model you know
did you find those growing up I thought
I did and then they screwed me over
uh financially
like what happened that doesn't sound
good yeah well they it's like I always
thought of um because I've been doing
social media since I was 14 and uh
there's you know fake social media
managers that'll get you deals but then
they just take your money
it's like a huge problem here in
California or in Los Angeles like uh
fake social media managers that are in
like their mid-20s to like early 30s and
then they say like oh I could do this
this this and this and they just end up
screwing you overtaking your money and
then the people that get their money
taken don't have enough money for legal
so then they just get to keep the money
you know I ran into similar situations
when we first started working there's so
we don't work with agents or managers or
anything for that reason because every
person we worked with was just like
scheming and we're like [__] this I'm
not working with anybody but I'm glad
you found someone honest to work with
with Pat Ryan Kavanaugh Brad Brad is my
manager yeah yeah he's the one that does
everything
um
he was so he was so disappointed bro
the face he made I hope he's I hope that
he's not either yeah I'm gonna get like
a little he's gonna he's gonna give you
a little scolding yeah
so but tell me about what happened were
you making money at a young age yeah
14 you were making money because you're
on like musically which is I was on
YouNow what is even you now it's a live
streaming uh Network I don't know if
it's still still up I'm looking up right
now I know it like completely died
around like 2016. this is what it looks
like looks like it hasn't been updated
since
that's crazy bro there's this whole
streaming it was like twitch
where they can are there still people
live right here let's click one
how many views is that yeah this guy's
30 viewers
popping
it's really best slow load bro
yeah I know you know used to be the
thing I was like averaging thousands of
viewers concurrently really so how did
you make money on uh YouNow it's tips
still you're getting tips yeah and so
you were doing like a pretty good I mean
I didn't make [__] when I was 14 so it's
been interesting yeah like my first
paycheck was like 2.5 k that's crazy
yeah and my mom didn't know like what I
did or even how I like was making money
she was like you should get a job I was
like and then uh she sees my first
paycheck of like 2.5 k and she's like
what do you do and I was like Mom 14 I
live stream
so she got sussed out
she's like what do you mean you live
stream as a 14 year old what do you do
what are you doing on life she's not
wrong that is pretty sus yeah no then
she started watching my live streams and
the reason I started live streaming was
because I didn't have any friends
so I wanted to talk to people
that's interesting you that hard you're
not that you're not like that much of a
punk dude you can't make friends at all
in school yeah I know people didn't like
me
huh that was weird no friends I had two
friends
so you go to you now
and um you start streaming and uh who's
watching you is it like girls yeah it's
mainly it was mainly girls
um there were some guys that thought
what I was doing was just stupid funny
what were you but I was just being
myself songs and [__] I was literally
being myself just prank calling doing
like 14 15 year old [__] you know okay
wow so you were kind of an early adopter
I mean I think you were in the game
before a lot of us nine years
and so you're on you now making a little
cheddar from that and then where do you
go musically and are you making money
for musically musically is what popped
me off
I remember I read that you got like um
you had like a million followers you
were big on that I was one of the bigger
creators on musically yeah and then that
and did that help you reduce the
bullying being on musically actually
Amplified was were you in high school
when you were doing that it was
literally just a regular high school kid
doing like those musicallys yeah people
must have gone crazy for that dude
walking in the Halls just like kids
holding it up kind of jealous though
because you were blowing up dude making
money it's like who the [__] are they
yeah I know but it's like when you're
young you don't understand how stupid
um
high school is in general like people
making fun of you bullying it's just all
so stupid and it shouldn't really get to
you but it it does when you're yeah in
that environment and that's the only
environment you know you haven't seen
the real world
talk to me about like I'm genuinely
curious like what does it mean bowling
like you would go to school you have two
friends you hang out with and people
would like like what would people do
yeah so we had four different lunch
periods in my school
um and I was just hoping that my two
friends would be in my lunch food so I
like could sit with people I literally
didn't have a table to sit at so I would
uh get my food and act like I'm going to
the bathroom and I would go to the
bathroom and just eat my food in a stall
Jesus bro that was so bad like really
[__] sad it's so it's so weird to say
out loud and people were taking shits
next to you and you were eating your
mind eating my food gnarly
yeah no
um and then it did it was just like you
know the typical
high school bullying it was like people
would try to fight me people would like
shoulder check me knock my [__] out of
my hand
call me names stupid people kids are so
[__] up it's like looking back now
it's hilariously it's like [__]
psychotic yeah no but I think it's just
so funny and stupid but I mean
although you're pretty you're I'm the
oldest [__] I'm 37 so for you you're 24
you've been out of high school for a
while but it's not that far behind you
either yeah no I I'm turning 24 in
August
so it'll be
what is that six years seven years
I mean it still affects you you know
would you go to a high school uh reunion
just to stunt on it oh yeah I'm totally
going to my high school reading really
yeah I wish they had like a five-year
one but they only do like the 10 years
so you got to keep it together for
another five years bro like another four
or three years I gotta keep it low don't
burn out don't get arrested no fights
yeah no I gotta keep it like chilling
good just yeah yeah I didn't go to any
of my high school reunions personally I
was just like whatever I bet they all
know what you do they definitely do you
think so 100 I was I kind of minded my
own business too I don't know if I was
like I had a few friends and we all kind
of just mind their own business you know
what I mean I feel like everyone in
Hollywood where uh we were like the
outcasts in high school
potentially yeah I would say I've been
an outcast but
um
it was fine you know it was fine but I
want I do wonder if they know what I do
I thought about love those people in
forever I mean you have a very
successful podcast I think they would
know that thanks bro yeah if you guys
are watching
I [__] made it losers idiot you're
getting bullied now [__] you that's
right if you didn't want to talk to me
what now they're like yeah you're still
beat I want to touch you even knowing
that you're rich
but like you are known as
a heartthrob right you accept that title
do you think so aren't you a hunk or two
the bad boy hunky guy I I mean I have my
days where I look good like right now I
look beat as hell you don't think you
look good I know I'm like looking beat
you guys all have the same haircut what
do you think about that oh I'm gonna cut
it I need my hair I need to cut my hair
it's so long
yeah you guys all kind of just throw it
Forward I just let my hair grow I don't
style it I just let it grow and then if
it gets too long I cut it got it so you
must have been getting some female
attention that when you lost the weight
oh yeah okay online not not okay that's
weird because they didn't know me you're
getting attention online but you go to
school and everyone hates you that must
have been weird to have like that double
life yeah it was it was like I was
living a real life Hannah Montana hmm
put on the wig put on the wig and then
nobody knows it's actually me and then I
take it off I'm like what am I listening
[__] me dude
and D were you a good student in high
school yeah
I had I had like some teachers that
didn't like me but then I had like a lot
of teachers that liked me
hmm
and uh so let's see you're on musically
you're popping how do you make money on
musically did they have like uh live
streaming oh live streaming the same way
so it's like it kind of just flowed from
my um my YouNow streams to musically
streams it was super easy and then from
that was it just straight to tick tock
yeah yeah well I did YouTube for about
like two years where musically was just
like dead and
um
yeah just it turned it I remember going
to the actual like event that musically
transferred over to tick tock and was
bought out by by dance or whatever
and I remember seeing it and and being
there I was a little drunk and I was
like the announcement they're on the
stage like making the announcement I'm
like this is not gonna work this is the
stupidest thing this is hilarious and it
popped off which was
funny I wonder I mean I'm surprised
because uh
so what was that what is it called
before it was tick tock musically
musically seemed like musical.ly that
seemed like the weirdest silliest [__] I
have ever seen in my life I think the
video Concepts were so stupid I don't
even know how they were getting popular
it was like filmed in 0.5 and you're
just like dude I was like what the [__]
is going on with these kids and I mean
looking back now let me pull up some of
these do I have some of these do you
wash these back and like cringe or are
you just kind of like whatever oh yeah I
get haunted by them I think it's like a
funny it's like a funny joke on Tick
Tock for people to like just keep
tagging me in them yeah
I'm gonna mute the music but I mean yeah
it's bad you're making it though dude
people were loving this look at me
though so weird were you one of the
better lip singers do you think on that
app I have no idea what the attraction
to that was like what is that
look I'm just in the middle of like a
workout and I'm just like wait hold up
gotta do my musically
so is this what you looked like was this
the kid who was getting bullied at
school yeah now that I'm actually like
looking back at it I can see why
no everything I'm just kidding everybody
looked like that it was like the the
Justin Bieber 2015 hair
homies there bro yeah me and my boys
hold on hold on hold on well that I got
more friends in this room than I had in
high school that's in La okay this is
after yeah this is in L.A was it weird
to come to LA and then have like friends
for the first time yeah and especially
like because it was like my first time
meeting like online kids in person
because I was friends with them over
um
over social media so then I I me meet
these people that I was just texting and
FaceTiming in person it was it was like
my first friends I was like holy [__] I
have friends hmm
kind of cool yeah cool you know um
that's funny I got older and I have no
friends now so that's kind of an
interesting Dynamic you have that to
look for I mean I have I have like
probably five friends yeah that's a lot
like having like five close homies then
I can just be like yo these are my
homies so I wanna so you grew up you
come out of high school you moved to LA
it's kind of all happening for you uh
and
here you are how is it what's your like
your main source of income these days
um right now I think the I think it's
like mostly every Creator that's on this
program but Snapchat [__] I've heard
about Snapchat yeah
how many views do your videos get there
um my stories get anywhere between
50 to 100 million
views yeah per story per per like full
story
50 to 100 million yeah I mean what the
[__] some days it's like 300 million
wait wait do you guys use Snap I've
never used Snapchat I use it yeah yeah
and there's that there's even that many
people no there's a difference between
no it's how many people are viewing your
story so it's not 350 million different
people hmm it's like one story and I'll
post like 100 stories so it's like one
story two story they'd watch 100
views in one sitting if they watch my
whole story and so Snapchat they put ads
in between the stores I heard the CPM
there's [__] crazy dude it's it's
amazing it's the only uh platform that
actually pays the creators so are you
doing like seven digits plus from
Snapchat
I'm making good money and is Brad the
bull take a cut of that Brad is the one
that got me on that program there you go
he'd [__] so there you go you
actually did you know it's so funny
because he and Brad get me on that he
actually probably could hey tell Brad he
can take a cut of my pie any day hey my
wife right here table though Brad you
hearing this
no he uh Brad I just your boy just got
you a new customer he grew up with the
owner of Snapchat how crazy no way so he
was like Hey can you can I get my client
on here what a guy yeah you tell you
tell Brad give me a call I actually I
will if you want to be on the program
I'm sure Brad can get you on the program
a thousand percent I've been trying to
I've had like companies reach out
they're like hey we think your podcast
would do really good on Snapchat uh
we're gonna try well you're thinking of
a snap show but even stories are
monetized
dude what is going on over there yeah
spotlights there's um there's the
stories and then there's the shows I
just started the show oh you did a show
is that in collaboration with Snapchat
um yes yeah it's um
I think the show is called Million
Dollar Listing it's on TV that's uh with
the and I know that show YouTube
Brothers
you during a realtor show I'm uh touring
houses on my Snapchat okay interesting
which is pretty cool yeah no I know that
one guess who got me to connect with the
Altman brothers that had to be your boy
Brad Brad the real estate hold on Brad
seems like he knows what the [__] he's
doing Brad is a g I gotta say as far as
managers go
maybe this could work out great maybe
Brad can be my manager and um maybe kav
Kev well let's see could me and Kev ever
be friends what do you guys think
probably I think I I genuinely think if
you guys had a conversation offline
and then plan something to come online
on this podcast
yeah you guys would have a good good
conversation yeah
it's just that your fans definitely
don't like Kavanaugh well they're not
the only ones yeah you and your fans
whatever you you say your fans will do
that's not true hey my favorite fans are
just like you I see the tweets they're
hilarious my fans they act on their own
accord
any ideas they get from me there's no
ideas for me
right but you could definitely influence
them never I would never do that
um so
uh you know
I want to ask you about your mushroom
trip because I know you're whatever it's
like silly but I've done a lot of drugs
and psychedelics I think it's
frankly
I think it's a really important
coming-of-age thing for people
if I if I were to try to explain my
mushroom
trip I literally um
you know how psychedelics work it's it's
like so hard to explain When You're
Sober uh the exact moment and try to put
into words what you saw
um
but basically what I saw if I were to
try to put it into words
I saw myself I saw like this weird
figure around me that was persuading me
to do things that wasn't me it was it
was really weird about like I I was
acting a Persona and I saw it
like I was looking at myself
and it wasn't me
hmm
and how did you interpret that I saw it
as something was persuading me not to
reach my full potential apparently
that's called ego death that's like when
you're really blasted oh I took probably
like 10 grams of mushrooms how much is a
quarter that's how much I took when I
did it or an eighth three and a half
grams they do or quarters three and a
half and you took how much ten bro
that's pretty heavy duty is that a lot
Dan I'm not sure 10 what 10 grams
yeah that's a lot a lot because a gram
is uh an eighth you'll start seeing
stuff on three and a half no I was
blasted dude I don't remember how much I
took but I was [__] I think it was
important I mainly even did it just
because
um my friend who doesn't do he doesn't
even smoke weed but he was so drunk and
someone gave him mushrooms
so I was like dude how many mushrooms
did you just take he goes just this cup
full and I was like bro you're about to
trip and he I saw in his face like he's
like what I'm like all right dude I
gotta guide you man so I grabbed like a
bunch and I just started taking not
gonna do much guiding oh no I didn't
guide anything I actually think I made
it worse
so I did I smoked crack once by the way
yeah just one
um so you're in this ego death you're
seeing like a version of yourself
and I think that probably made a lot of
sense to you so what is it that how did
you interpret that I I think my that the
overall message was
um my brain basically saying stop acting
this way this is this is not who you are
people like you for you
um show it to yourself and what kind of
behavior is that in reference to so I
was basically doing like on my come up I
was trying to do anything that got views
I was doing the most [__] up [__]
just to get attention and that's all I
wanted I didn't see hate I didn't see
love I saw views I saw people I saw
people watching me people talking about
me and I loved it just the attention
aspect I loved it you look at hate
comments and you were happy
dying laughing I was thinking I was
thinking it was the funniest thing do
you think and then I didn't realize
looking at it from an outside
perspective how much of a little
douchebag I looked like
[Music]
do you think that has part of maybe to
do with the fact that you grew up
without a dad like attention seeking
Behavior
yeah and then some girls will say it's
because of my zodiac sign
what's your zodiac sign I'm a Leo I
don't know what that means is that all
terrible but I don't actually know
anything
a Leo is like an attention seeker do you
believe in all that no
good for you
[Laughter]
yeah but uh have you done therapy and
stuff to work out issues have you
explored that yeah how long did you are
you still doing it did you do it for a
while
I did uh I think like seven eight
sessions
um
not a lot I thought it was so stupid you
didn't like it I hated it was it not
saying it doesn't work for some people
because I can see how that works for
some people but I just don't like
talking to somebody about my problems
when I can fix everything myself yeah
you dude that's not you that's really it
sounds like you need therapy
everything myself see that's what I'm
saying though like I I can't you need
therapy badly bro I can't even put it
into words like I'm just like I I don't
think somebody all your own problems I
think so
I think everything just all is rooted
from my problems so it's like that's my
my duty to fix my problems yeah but
sometimes the problems within us require
it's not weak to ask people for help
sometimes we need help sometimes I go I
like I appreciate advice I appreciate
advice but uh I think it was my
therapist just the way that they were
speaking to me like I was like a little
kid were they good how'd you find them I
I was assigned to them
oh
Goodwill Hunting stuff wait wait wait
wait wait how why were you assigned to
them um because someone said that I
needed therapy okay tell me about this
this is interesting
um it was mainly because of my the way
that I was acting I I've crew like I
have major ADHD I was like an outcast in
high school I'd I would like move around
I wasn't acting like everyone else and
they
saw my sudden bursts of energy
okay and they thought it was unnatural
so they they assigned me with a
therapist so this was like a school
issued one yeah you must have been a
real [__] problem though for them to
make you go see a therapist yeah well I
wouldn't even say I was a problem I was
just like
I was impulsive I was like
I couldn't sit still I was uh I was
moving around like I couldn't I
literally just could not sit in a desk
do stuff for hours at a time and and not
like
right do something so did you ever get
medicated for the ADHD yeah they gave me
Focalin
and did that help you no no it made me a
zombie okay so you're not on that no no
and uh Olivia says she's a Leo and she
says she vouches we do need therapy she
says we need therapy you think so plus
Leo's need lots of therapy
wait are you a Leo I'm not I'm a cancer
what what a day
July 29th oh so you made the cut barely
still a Leo what are you talking about
Leo's Leo and we need therapy apparently
I'm barely a cancer I'm like a cancer by
default
yeah no I'm August 14th so
I'm like Prime Leo there's never been a
problem in your life that you needed to
somebody else's help to resolve huh
you've never had a problem you need
someone else's help to resolve
never
I mean I think like that's just uh a 23
year old answer yeah you sound a little
arrogant sounds like you haven't been
well you've been through a lot of [__]
and you do have like uh it seems like
emotional you have like I saw a video of
you getting a fight in Las Vegas like a
few months ago yeah is that that's
embarrassing right it's got to be oh no
it was terribly embarrassing yeah
so that was that was after your mushroom
trip right I was very intoxicated as you
can tell in the video
yeah this is my first time even uh
talking about that really so what
happened there I yeah what happened I'm
still doing that legally so I don't want
to oh [__] you got sued did you get sued
for that uh no
what do you mean you're doing it legally
um I it's like for charges oh you got
charged for that yeah
let's go it's actually so annoying well
hold on you did punch a dude in the face
yeah but like you didn't see the video
that's fine I don't want to get you
especially I don't want to get you in
trouble with the law yeah it's just like
I think it's very annoying that
um people will provoke people in my
um in my space or like people like that
have a status they'll provoke them
to get them to do something outlandish
and then they'll they'll just sue them
for acting like a normal human being in
a city I never got in a fight like that
yeah well
imagine getting like just bugged and
touched and pushed and and your your
head's getting pushed your your arms
getting pushed and you're telling these
people to stop doing something and they
continue to do it and then when you act
upon it like a normal human being you
get sued and and by acting upon it is
what like hitting them so like someone
someone provokes you they keep touching
you they keep pushing you and then you
punch them and they like say oh man
right I can't believe you did that now
I'm Gonna Take This legal and sue you
for money
like it's so annoying it's actually what
did you get charged for
um battering assault
which in Las Vegas which yeah I did act
out of character and it was it was very
stupid it was influenced by alcohol but
I'm not blaming it on that but also just
I just hate the way people treat certain
people
right but it also happened before that
where you got in a fight at like a
hookah lounge
there was like a crazy scrap but with uh
uh what what was is that a restaurant or
something oh the the restaurant one yeah
yeah that was in 2020. so it was a few
years ago but are all your fights being
recorded or their fights you're having
that aren't recorded
um
I have a lot of fights that are recorded
but that one I mean I'm still they're
still they sued me so bro you got some
issues
you're being sued you got problems bro
you're being you're being strong yeah I
just need therapy you you need lots of
therapy you need to but you need so you
got charged
in Las Vegas criminally not not
officially
yeah like so I'm handling we're handling
all that and and honestly the guys after
were very cool like we we all talked
about it after and like we shook hands
and it was like but he still sued you no
no the guy in Vegas okay we're we're
very cool with that they were actually
very nice guys after which was
surprising to me yeah um but the
restaurant guys
yeah like that I think that Situation's
out there so I mean like it's all in the
lawsuit he basically
claimed a bunch of false [__]
um he put in a lawsuit that
you want to talk about defamation this
guy's basically saying that I was
calling him uh racial slurs right he's
he's this is okay let me let me let me
just explain this
um actually j-rod was there
um Jay Road who's j-rod j-rod
remember the the Cinco incident
yeah you can talk into the mic j-rod we
have a camera and Mike there who's j-rod
uh this is this is my videographer the
goat the best videographer editor in the
system can you hear me like in the game
best videographer in the game James
editor and editor in the game I don't
even say that yeah you are Jared you're
being humble no that's Hayden and
there's there's a lot of big editors
you're definitely top five so what
happened
um so basically we were out there we
were going golfing for a YouTube bit
yeah
um but we wanted food uh before and like
a few drinks so we went to this local
Mexican restaurant we were like hey
let's get some food let's get some
drinks and then let's go golf let's
let's do something like cool for the
video
um
we were in like an outdoor Terrace
we were I think we took like what two
tequila shots I took like two shots at
most yeah like two tequila shots and
then we got our food I paid for it I'm
waiting for it they uh it's an outdoor
Terrace so I hit my vape okay and then
they come up to me and they say hey uh
don't vape and I was like oh yeah my bad
my bad I put my vape in my pocket okay
and then
they uh they come back like five minutes
later
with my vape in my pocket and everybody
just chilling talking and we're like
laughing you know just having a good
time they say hey if you vape Again by
the way we're gonna kick you out and and
I was like this is five minutes later I
was like no one no one Vape that time
what are you what are you talking about
they must have thought they saw you
vaping yeah but I was like no one Vaped
look My Vapes in my did he hit the Vape
j-rod
oh no you heard it here from j-rod and
and you wouldn't lie about it would you
no never it's vaping it's not a big deal
but it's like it it was not that big of
a deal so then
um I give them my card to pay
um and the guy starts saying like hey we
saw you vape again and nobody Vaped like
I would I would be completely honest
with you guys if I was in the wrong here
I no one Vaped that okay and they ran
over it was like they ran over from a
sitcom they're yelling in my face like
getting very very aggressive in my face
my friend Rory who was with us jumps in
front of me and they start arguing the
the guy like then pushes Rory
and I was like yo let's like why why are
we getting physical let's like just talk
like normal adults and then uh he ended
up tackling my friend to the ground the
manager of this restaurant tackling my
friend to the ground so then I jumped on
top of them
um and I put him in a Chokehold dude
that's [__] crazy dude and I put him
in a Chokehold and then that's a lot
and then like yeah just you see the
video like the video starts when I'm I
put him in a choke hold and then that's
like when all the craziness happens and
then we go away but I wasn't I wasn't I
didn't have my card yet like they they
took my card and they refused to give it
back to me that was after the fight so
then I was just like okay whatever I'll
just leave my card but then
seven months eight months maybe even a
year later uh this guy sends a lawsuit
uh basically saying that I said racial
slurs to him
that I was being uh did you hear racial
slurs I did not hear right he did not
hear racial slurs j-rod which is
absolutely ridiculous this is in 2020
Prime every camera is on me I believe
you went like that yeah in a public
setting but he also just it was it was
crazy that he would even say that and
then people are running with it people
genuinely think that I was being racist
towards uh Hispanics and but it was
mostly he said that you like injured him
it's like a lot of stuff he put in there
yeah he also kicked me in my nuts but
you don't see me crying about it and
freaking
that almost came back up out of my
throat right it actually is right here
that's what this thing is right it
hasn't gone back down yet
um
and so you're being you're being sued by
this guy you're being sued are you
afraid though in a way like you're
successful you have a lot to lose now
you know you got a good income you got a
lot going on you got good friend
powerful friends
um you are you you're gonna what if
something like really bad happens with
in these confrontations you know what I
mean like you got to be afraid that
something worse can happen somebody gets
hurt accidentally you're in jail yeah
um it genuinely just never
um happens it I mean it does it's like
once in a blue moon and I now go out uh
every single time when I go to a setting
where there's alcohol I bring a security
guard which I I hate doing that I don't
like to be that guy that passed to bring
a security guard but I now go out every
single time to make sure that every
situation is de-escalated by just paying
this guy to make sure it doesn't get to
that point is that right j-rod
he hasn't came out with me in a while
he's got a bit he's been a while since
we since we got out but yeah you don't
bring j-rod out
um I haven't went out in in LA in a long
time
you've had it you've had a break
from partying like you guys drink
together ever though j-rod hey we're
having a we're having a simple blackout
right now isn't that right j-rod do you
have yours over there uh it's not open
because I was saving it for one of the
crew members can I ask you a question
what does your mom call you
Jonathan Jonathan Jonathan it's so weird
when someone calls him Jonathan but
everyone everyone else calls you j-rod
here now Jonathan Rodriguez but at home
okay that's dumb Jonathan Rodriguez
j-rod I like that it's like A-Rod ripoff
but it'd be so weird if I was like yo
Jonathan come over here I just wouldn't
answer you well you are like apparently
the A-Rod of editing is that right
I don't say that I don't know why he's
saying that but yeah he knows he says it
about you A-Rod don't be humble he's
he's really he's being humble and it's
that's that's what makes him one of the
best thank you
I'm gonna have some blackout now because
you said that yeah can you can you take
a little sip of that blackout tell me
how it tastes since I was here when he
was making it kinda so but you actually
did come to the first um
the first factory
where we were producing blackout
that's good thanks man it's better than
white clouds a little sweeter he's never
tried it before uh he didn't try the new
this is like the final product this is
the final product Rod my boy let's get a
lit people are saying W I just want to
be friends with them with a name like
that yeah no worries maybe all of us
let's go to the local Mexican restaurant
we'll see what happens
let me get your number after this
brother
j-rod let's [__] go
J Rod hey tell me this keep it up keep
it up
[Applause]
um you say you don't need therapy you
say you don't need help but I personally
see from this vantage point someone who
has a lot of opportunity someone who has
a lot
um
of success and I don't want you to ruin
it because I do see someone that you
know has some has trouble rightfully so
right I mean
um
and you've been in fights recently and I
just hate to see that I don't want to
see you like waste a good opportunity
but you don't think you need help
I mean uh I am taking like anger classes
oh that's that's good that's really good
I don't think therapy well that is kind
of therapy isn't it is that I think so
then I guess yes what are the anger
classes like
um
so it's so funny feels silly it's it is
it's like all right if somebody does
this how do you react and they give you
like 10 seconds
they're like count to ten in your head
and
if it doesn't seem like a good a good
decision you don't do it correct and I'm
like yeah yeah no that's that doesn't
seem like real world training like isn't
it crazy it's like someone's like
yelling in your face hold up one second
let me consider my options yeah although
it's better than you know what I'm gonna
walk away now well have you have you
applied that you know it's crazy so yeah
there's um there's like clips of me
getting in fights but you'll never see
the clips that go viral of me not
engaging right I'll never see me
interesting yeah no there's there's like
uh Jared were you there when that girl
just threw Rod threw water in my face in
that casino no
I saw a video of someone just snagging
your hat for no reason like being a
total dick yeah but no I was at a casino
and there are these two people
recognized me they're like hey can we
can we take a picture and I'm like yeah
yeah of course of course girl has a a
thing of water throws it in my face
that's crazy throws in my face and I
just sit there wow just like
that was really funny and then it and
then they walk away and I'm just like
how come that couldn't go viral where
I'm actually like calm i i that's so
[__] up why did it why would she do
that because I was a hated guy on the
internet and she thought it was funny
well you can't deck a girl even oh no
that wasn't an option probably I mean no
I wasn't going to decorate yeah
did you feel angry and then you kind of
yeah got through it obviously I was
angry yeah it's just water thrown in my
face I was like all wet how often are
you doing the anger classes
I have to do them um once a week you're
being forced to do anger management
classes well I'm also I'd like need them
so I I'm support ordered I'm doing them
once a week for um for the court yeah
this is part of what happened in Vegas
yeah and how long do you have to do that
um I think I have another like a month
or two
that's interesting so it seems like
it's actually doing something for you
yeah I've done them before I've done
anger your ass has been in Anger
Management yeah in high school
are you in other people in the class
with you
in the anger management classes that
other people it's just a one-on-one yeah
that'd be embarrassing
I don't know because when the court
orders you I I imagine there's like like
an AAA meeting or something it's like
what are you in for ah just punched a
hole in my wall freaking pissed
j-rod you get angry
I'm so angry Gerald's probably one of
the angry guys Jared's probably one of
the nicest guys like ever yeah you seem
like I don't get angry I don't I don't
know what it is I've never been angry
I've never gotten in a fight
okay
that's Kevin
I don't remember what was the context of
that one driving it was a movie
oh Drive Angry
um
do you ever still feel like you're
bullied do you ever still feel like
insecure in that way when people come up
and throw drinks in your face and grab
your hat you give does it give you like
flashbacks yeah and that's why I react
the way that I do sometimes and it's
very stupid as a 23 year old man that I
react like that but it makes sense
that's why therapy is important these
are deep
issues you know you'd be surprised how
deep they go if you find a good
therapist
recently I I mean besides that like
Vegas incident it's been very great like
I have not gotten angry you've moved a
little bit to the center of the frame
yeah yeah thank you I just scoop forward
a little touch there nice
um
yeah but that's gotta feel I feel like
you know
do you ever like question people like
are you really my friend because you've
been bullied you you don't have like
growing up with strong relationships
it's got to have some strain on your
relationships these days yeah I have a I
have a very small uh group of friends
but like yeah they're my boys I can I
can tell you they've de-escalated
situations for me what about romantic
relationships are you do you find that
you're able to kill I mean you had a
actually a famously uh pretty long
relationship with Addison yeah for two
years
that's actually pretty long yeah pretty
committed very young kid yeah I haven't
had one since
have you tried or have you just kind of
been
doing whatever
yeah I haven't really tried but I feel
like when I try I don't find anything
like when I when I uh when I just kind
of let it float it happens I see
okay let's talk I want to ask you about
uh FouseyTUBE
he's kind of a friend a satellite friend
of the show
you did this show with him
and this clip actually tickled me quite
a bit
uh there's one where you where he was
hitting on you and then there was one
where you punched him which one came
first chronologically
um
he was throughout the entire show he was
like trying to fight me and then also
like doing weird stuff by grabbing me
and kissing you were 100 Justified I saw
this [__] it's weird as [__] so weird
like I I I was
I was just shocked so wait I've never
seen him act like this did you punch him
first or was this interview of him like
groping you and saying he he wanted you
to that was his dick I punched him after
that okay so let's watch that one first
then because I have all these clips I
felt gay
that's do you I wouldn't quite I want to
assume to guess his sexuality but
um
would you
I said I wouldn't assume to guess the
sexuality but would you yo bro don't
[__] Vape in here no I'm just kidding
I have no idea what what that was
what is this show what is this this was
Keenan JC's uh Reality House
people watch this I guess oh yeah 1.8
million
yeah there's a there's a lot
um this is like a a very viral series of
theirs they they do like a reality show
I think once a year
I don't even know the [__] they are and
they have like yeah they have a bunch of
like social media people come in
this is them yeah sure have you ever
you've heard of O2L
O2 oh I haven't really have you heard of
O2L yeah what is O2L it's like a Connor
Franta uh Trevor Moran I don't know who
any of those people Cannon JC who am I
missing I know Keenan Dylan oh Ricky
dylan that's the only Keenan I [__] with
yeah no it was it was a very big group
but then uh Kanan JC separated and then
they just created a channel together I
see so here is an excerpt first I guess
fousey was getting really warm to you
here is a clip of it oh God
what do you want to say we're not
talking about you yet what do you want
to say I know you want to say Bryce were
you guys having trouble already at this
point yeah yeah he he seems like he was
really was he drunk all the time I mean
we were all like that was the whole
point yeah yeah we that's the point of
like getting in a reality house
everyone's in an uncomfortable setting
so it's like you drink a little bit to
loosen up but I I don't know what he was
on okay so here it is your breath still
smells like tuna I bet it does and it
does I bet it does it really does I put
you on the canvas would you yeah he
keeps trying to fight which is funny
okay because you didn't you you [__]
knocked his ass out
so that so your your threat proved to be
true turns me on okay I only watch porn
two times a week I don't know what that
means
I've never been through clout or fame I
would stick your head back like this and
make you take every inch of my dude that
that is that is disturbing actually that
part there I was like gay that's pretty
weird man every inch every inch bro like
what so I think of them I do feel like
he really wants to [__] you
yeah yeah you got them yeah
yeah I don't know it was really it was
really weird
do you guys want to form an alliance how
okay so that was that yeah
um but then throughout the entire thing
he was just like saying yeah Bryce I
want to box you I want to box you I want
to fight you when he was sober do you
have a problem with you
um he would always make jokes about that
and then like you'd always like bring up
the Austin [__] and I would just tell
him like dude yeah I got my ass guy cool
cool I was dude nobody got their ass
kicked harder than Foose yeah I know
looked like he went through it and I was
like bro like you have no room to talk
yeah dude zero room to talk and he
needed like facial reconstruction
surgery he did you got a nose job from
it
um do you feel like he was bullying you
I mean it was like trying to he was
attempting but it's like it wasn't
getting it was more just annoying
because I'm like dude you literally had
to get face surgery after your first
YouTube of all people like what is it
about you that makes people want to
bully you
about me
let me reword that I was like about me
or about food do you ever feel like why
but why would fusi try to even pick on
you I don't understand why
he would think that he could do that or
why would he just like they think it's
like funny I think it's like a like
I'm hated on the internet so picking on
me
would make the general public oh true
it's that
everyone thinks you're the villain so
they can [__] with you and look funny
yeah right so so I was just like not
having it that makes sense I see that I
think I had a little bit of that too
when I look back at the Frenemies clip
because I watched it last night and I
was like I was way out of pot like I was
just way over there it was I mean it was
just the general public it was like the
thing to do did you get over people just
hating you that much or you didn't no I
never I'd never like it I never cared
but this is like
this is like me just out of that zone
I'm not I'm not acting like that anymore
you don't want to be hated anymore yeah
no and then and then he just
continuously keeps bringing up my past
okay that makes sense the answering with
me and touching my neck and telling me
that that he's gonna [__] me like it was
weird
yo play his whole acceptance speech
I'm gonna get your table worthless
the whole thing
I don't even know how or why he won that
it must have been like [__] 2016 17 or
which year was it you have the whole
speech there Zaki uh yeah yeah I want to
hear that I played it yeah yeah I felt
worthless no not that the whole thing oh
no I don't have the whole thing 2016 he
won
it's so uh if you haven't seen it it's
very powerful in fact I think it's worth
it you'll hear me now what here it is
what's the deal with Lula why is he in
every [__] thing who
Lula
is that him that's him maybe it's just
me I just feel like he's in every God
he's at every award show it's like bro
take a break
I've never seen that guy looks like
fousey just gave him every inch uh what
is that in his mouth yeah I don't know
all right where's the fousey [__] here
let's see you're gonna like this
has this got claimed for us previously
it has man the [__] them bro
play some weird music over or play that
where where where
here I'll make it small we'll play some
music
first off I want to dedicate this award
to the dofra as the best family on
YouTube
second off this year I became one of the
most hated YouTubers on the platform
that's maybe because I let ricegum punch
me in the face or maybe because I came
out and said 99 of the pranks on YouTube
are fake but I want to say this the
music for a long time I looked at myself
in the mirror and I based myself based
on what I read on the comments I felt
worthless I felt ugly I felt gay I felt
that no like that's based on what they
told me
but I reminded myself to two everyone
just like what I have to use for myself
whenever I was fighting so that that
spawned one of the greatest uh podcast
memes we always play uh I felt worthless
I felt ugly I felt gay yeah I felt that
no then like that's based on what they
told me yeah I did so that's you know
but we like fousey bro we love him
but I do I wouldn't speculate about uh
something so serious though
Lucy here is uh him when you knock him
out stop oh God foosies
yeah we just watch that let me find the
other link
here it is yeah so so what happened here
do you remember when he like grabbed the
girl's face and like pushed her yes
so he did that and this is just
basically us uh saying like dude it was
it's like it's [__] up like you can
move on from it just like apologize
right and he's like Bryce no like I've
defended you on so many things and like
he was basically implying that I've done
something similar
so I then immediately responded I said
like what what have you what has even
remotely came close to me pushing a Girl
by her face like what could you compare
anything that I've done to me to you
laying your hands on a woman's face and
pushing a girl that you just met by her
head and he was just like no no trust me
trust me I was like what dude he was a
mess in this show yeah and so uh well
here it is for your viewing pleasure
oh
yeah that he says I know so much [__] on
you that I protected you about it's like
but like what I'm like you can explain
you owe me so much bro what so much
[Music]
[Applause]
so [__] mess such a mess this thing
bro
like
none of us like touching a long time
did you [__] slap him uh yeah it looks
like you open hand slapped his ass it
was a punch it was you got him good man
you knocked him out cold
did he like pass out
yeah I mean like dude we talked about it
after too
and he basically like apologized for
everything and and I apologize for
hitting him that's good um but it was
like a lot of built up stuff throughout
this entire day that he was just doing
those
you guys just left his ass on the floor
they told us to holy [__] dude they told
us to oh wow they told us to if it
wasn't our decision let him
oh [__]
I'm surprised you didn't get kicked off
the show first I did you did
it it was fully understandable like did
you get into any like serious trouble
for that one no no
we were we were both
drunk and like stupid we both like shook
hands after like we we made up after
everything you know fousey for all the
Goofs he doesn't seem like a bad guy
he's not a bad guy he just does like
trouble it's like a good guy that does
stupid things you know someone like that
yeah like myself
um
what is this one oh here's the clip of
fousey putting his hands on her yeah I
remember when this happened
extra as those girls say and the lady
said that was so yeah that was and he
like he pushed way too hard it wasn't
like talk to the hand and it was also
like you just met this girl like five
minutes you did that's wild
he pushed so hard yeah that was out of
pocket for sure
you went on like a massive sober uh
sober thing after he got in great shape
and then he got his ass beat yeah I mean
I I knew that was good at all
see we've never had him in here have we
we have not have we ever tried to reach
out to fishy no but I see him everywhere
I go you see him all the time four or
five times when I lived in the valley
I've seen him since that uh deji fight
how's he look he seems good
yeah his face looked [__] up no he
looked he looked pretty I think he had
to get surgery again
good I was like after that first fight
was one of the most brutal things I've
ever seen in Combat Sports
and I was like please don't get back in
the ring bro
I mean I knew that that was gonna happen
I literally even I even told deji I was
like bro he's not gonna touch you
and you're just gonna like you're gonna
get your first win he made deji look
like Mike Tyson dude yeah
that dude ain't one hasn't won a fight
either but now he's a 1-0 pro fighter
yeah
oh [__] poor [__] man
from creator of the Year being left
[__] lifeless on the cold concrete
Force that's carpet oh it's carpet yeah
that's good good thing that's not bad
that's not bad yeah that would have been
[__] up yeah nice warm carpet
he said
oh foosie
okay
[Laughter]
oh didn't we get a new gay drop from uh
Elon
did we play it on the show not yet I
think you may show is that the Asian
Elon Musk
yeah that guy is hilarious everyone we
tried to get him on the show okay he
doesn't speak any English though no he
doesn't yeah I don't but we try to get
him on the phone I guess through
translator and he like shook us down
hard we offered to pay him like a
thousand dollars just to call in
something like that and he basically
said are you [__] kidding he's like
that's not worth my time idiot he's like
do you know who I am it's like a
thousand bucks does he actually look
like that or is that CGI it's a deep
fake okay yeah okay but I was just
surprised I was like does anyone know
what he actually looks like
I don't
I don't think so yeah because I was like
dude he resembles Elon Musk so much it's
a really good deep fake and what's
interesting he kind of was ahead of the
game with the two before it became real
popular I mean is he still doing this
yeah I did talk to him on [__] like
telegram too which is weird
I just figured like a thousand I mean I
usually don't offer pay people to do
anything on the shows it was like a
thousand bucks just calling for like 10
minutes big [__] name dude he's like
spit on your face [__] you know who the
[__] I am
standard
Wester College
I for UK UT so that's it so I feel gay
you think so
we have a collection of people saying I
feel gay I feel I am gay so can you play
that one Zach I am gay that's Cuomo
today
uh Andrew Cuomo the former uh uh
governor of New York during the covid he
said he was gay he
he was doing a speech and he said it and
a lot of people have done that so the
FIFA guy
I am black I am Jewish I am a Muslim I
am gay
play the FIFA guy and
it's all straight people it's all
straight people yeah I was bullied
because I had red hair
and then there's the uh these are all
straight guys saying they felt gay it's
funny so there's Cuomo there's a a
who's the uh the Hakeem Jeffries dude
there's three main ones you're a
Christian we are Jewish we are Muslim we
are Hindu we are religious we are
secular we are gay we are straight so
now when you combine all three
okay this is a powerful moment
that was very powerful for you okay
power I'm gonna have to add the Elon
video heck yeah to the mega now play
this one again is it hitting
I feel okay
it's good it's very rhythmic like I feel
like you could do a song oh yeah
that's awesome
it's definitely a Bop Scorpio
laugh for me
we love your ass bro we love it always
and forever my dude I just want to see
what he actually looks like
yeah I'd love to see that but okay
anyway
um
Lucy uh
you are watching
uh I hope he I hope he gets better
can you just
that was terrible timing with with me
saying I hope he gets better I love that
hat talk to fousey I think it'd be
interesting you know he went uh he went
sober so that was like really good for
him
um gotten like really good shape his
mental game was just back to like normal
okay
um nice yeah he still hangs out with
keemstar intriguing
what's your what's your beef with
keemstar
well
as a Jewish man you might as well just
ask me what's my problem with Hitler
what does he do about that it's so did
Laura with keemstar so deep I mean he's
just a terrible dude
he's ripped into me like now he likes me
but like he used to rip into me yeah but
if you like say one thing about him not
nice he'll like lose his [__] and like
try to ruin your life like he's
he's the worst person
I I remember I he was like my uh
he was my YouTube channel that I would
have to keep up on all the drama with
but he doesn't do that anymore yeah yeah
people stop watching I saw I saw that uh
he stopped yeah I don't think he has any
presence anymore actually oh he
announced the your fight with Austin
yeah which is interesting because
I don't know like so did fousey
okay wow some some foreshadowing yeah oh
no and it was it was actually really
funny because like in the in the
announcement fousey's like saying all
right so it's proven that Bryce can take
a punch but uh those answers were
different I don't think he could
and I I'm literally just like shut up
Lucy like just shut up two great boxers
going head-to-head uh
in The Clash of the Titans I wanted to
talk about
um
let's squash the beef I kind of wanted
to review some of the [__] talking that
happened it's mostly my on my part
it's interesting can I go to the
bathroom yeah absolutely go ahead nope
take your time it's all good
keemstar and fousey those are those are
two little Five Guys they know if anyone
knows about boxing it's Lucy and thank
you baby the one thing they definitely
do know you know what they do know about
huh
beef jerky oh that is true maple syrup
bring me the steak bring me the vice
speaking of beef
what happened that's fine of course
[Music]
cue the sad music cue the meat what kind
of we got a nice one here 15 bucks what
the [__] did you buy this is just as gag
you know
you don't have to buy the goddamn
who bought the beat the New York strip
steak
[Music]
and nothing but the best this is the
cheapest they had damn
I'm not I'm not smashing this I'm gonna
eat this
that's 15 bucks for one steak I'm take
I'm eating this hell no Quality Meat
equals quality friendships there you go
you okay
yo I'm not do we got lunch meat or some
[__] straight up I'm not smashing this
we have the charcuterie don't waste
those I [__] eat those get them get
them a Lunchable I can't do it I can't
do it this is like a really nice steak
Who Says Yukon eat it afterwards bro
hell no it's tenderized yeah
[Music]
I respect me
I can't do that
I'm sorry I can't do it I didn't know
you were gay I'm not gay I just respect
meat maybe interestingly there's a lot
there's not a big difference between I
know you're gay
now here we're smashing something I
don't know what well we're gonna waste
these Salamis
yeah
yo we can't waste these Salamis
this is good salami
um
yeah lunchable me
you want a Lunchable
can we get Bryson lunchable please
do we have different varieties
I used to get those in my lunch bag
for sure I went through a stage of only
eating Lunchables really like one food
it was like it was literally just the
Lunchables without the the cookies that
sustained you interesting
oh my God
oh these are like the the higher end
Lunchables let me see it
these are so good oh thank you so much
like 11 grams of protein oh man
These are nice yeah these are the nice
ones what do you make of the uh
nutritional value to check out I mean I
think there's like 12 grams oh 16 grams
of protein it also has 50 saturated fat
that can be good I mean fats are good
especially when there's protein in it
what about 40 of your sodium in this one
thing that's crazy I don't track it like
that I track it like on uh calories
so this whole container has 300 calories
that's not bad that's not bad at all and
it's and you're gonna like get full off
of this what's your calorie intake like
2 300 ish a day
do you find that
you hit it
easy or do you find that you're hungry
at the end of the day oh I'm hungry
after so you're like when I'm walking
when I'm bulking I had taken like 3 500
to 4 000 calories a day so you're
cutting right now what for
just want to look good for summer 's
coming up boy we should we should go to
the gym together
you're not the first person to try to
get me on that
Brad everybody's trying to get my ass in
the gym
I saw him
sunshaft
he's always trying to get me in the gym
dude shut the [__] up damn
sent me an emergency note
he says you're choosing like food seeds
was chewing the cheese
I'm covering my mouth
so
where is Hassan
's on Thursday yeah we need we need like
a like a Hassan random cameo
um so I had a steak that I wanted to
squash but these guys bought like
a beautiful New York strip I said I'm
not smashing this so we're gonna do a
Lunchable but also didn't want to slam
the salami so we're just gonna we're
gonna squash the cheese
all right oh
we're supposed to be squashing the beef
[Music]
here's how this works
as I said this is mostly
things I did that I built that I could
apologize to you for
so if you'll for if we watch it and
you'll forgive me
then you can squash the cheese
okay
I think we already squashed it but like
let's squash the cheese officially okay
so here
from Frenemies
you know I haven't gone back and watched
any Frenemies Clips really this is the
first time
and when I saw this and
I feel like
I think a lot of people know this right
people say this all the time but
we were really nasty we were like really
mean
but I think that's what made it so
entertaining yeah we were we were catty
[__] for sure
price I'll be a [__] douche for a
minute
you got the douchebag of the week yeah I
did it was a big week for you though I
mean yeah it was yeah dude that guy he's
like on steroids or something I never
would never mind he's so unstable I just
every time I watch him he's so unstable
and mentally just I'm sorry we don't
have to watch this now let's keep
watching it so unhealthy well we know
what I like give him a diagnosis of
being unstable maybe he's fine maybe
he's trolling maybe no I'll look nice
sorry about that you too [__]
actually just called Jay Rod
j-rod is actually filming this exact
video we're reacting to King
and the girl passing by him a [__] okay
wait can you play it again he called
some random girl passing by a [__] can
I explain that his boyfriend came back I
was making it you know like um it was a
terrible joke but like
it's just like the the blunt humor of of
saying something
but just not meaning it in the slightest
I know what you mean yeah like like you
so out of pocket yeah I know it was so
out of pocket it was so out of pocket
and I realized it once I saw this exact
clip I was like oh yeah I guess that
does kind of look bad yeah I know back
when was like yo you better apologize
and he bitched out and got all let me
see beta
sorry about that YouTube [__] okay
immediately was like I'm actually so
sorry like I did not mean it like did
you ever think about cutting this from
your video J Rod edits it so Jared
yeah it was funny and also I corrected
him in the video I was like that's
[__] up I said that yeah we did we
both immediately agreed like yeah that
was funny not j-rod sorry it didn't it
didn't get actually any traction about
like how bad because like my Vlogs when
I was vlogging a lot
um it was just all jokes uh sarcastic
humor
um very not serious so like nothing that
we did really got like major traction
but when you reacted to it I realized I
was like okay that was I don't even know
how where we found this clip but it was
just a random one of my Vlogs did you
regret not removing this j-rod
now that I look back at it you know it
was it was rude but we also apologized
and I was like ass content j-rod have
has there ever been other moments you
regret not editing out of a video
not that I can think of now but probably
oh there's probably a lot of stuff Have
you ever got mad at j-rod you're like
bro you should have cut that what the
[__] well we would have just deleted the
video I I always watched we watched the
video probably like 15 times before we
post really yeah just in case there's
like addresses or anything said you guys
are like yo that [__] is slaps
I think it was because I apologized we
kept it in no because you did Apologize
real fast
okay whoever you are no no it was a joke
I'm sorry you apologize
it's funny because he's always the tough
guy in office Clips like fight me [__]
over and I was like ah you're a little
[__] actually in real life sorry bro
I was never like the the tough guy like
I would always like put on that I put on
like the Conor McGregor Persona one when
my fight promotion was happening I had
just seen a video of you like cruising
up to someone's house with cat food oh
yeah that was
that was stupid that was stupid it was
like I already told me that yeah
remember we were doing everything for
Content we were just trying to get like
as many people to watch no matter what I
did I guess it worked in a sense yeah it
was it was like working but also yeah to
the outside perspective I can see how
everyone [__] hated me
it was bad
I was doing like the you know how Jake
Paul pulled up on Digi with like the the
gloves
I don't remember that it looked like he
was he looked like the biggest church
but
um who was that guy no the guy that you
pulled up to his house or was like
what's up [__] I got cat food for you
also one thing I noticed is you took the
cat food back yeah I know it wasn't it
wasn't my cat food it was uh Thomas
Petro's cat food you couldn't have
bought him a new bag
um yeah no income wasn't as good yeah
[__] that's awesome you had to bring
the cat food back
that's good
because I always figured
you leave the cat food yeah I know way
more embarrassing for him yeah it would
have been funnier but it's like you you
don't want to put like the cat food to
waste right it's like he was gonna
protect the cats yeah he was just gonna
like throw it away so it's like I wanted
to defeated an actual cat
got it a girl too I was like you're okay
okay so that's it so Scotty sire
apparently we saw him [__] Hall
I like that no we we almost moved on and
then Trisha said call him [__] Hall
her joke not mine that's [__] up
Trisha that was [__] up
okay [__] Hall he wants to come on our
show so bad and fight and like try to
like he thought I was gonna fight you if
I got you we're gonna try to do
something oh message me I think and you
said you wanted to come on yeah yeah no
no because I think uh Trisha said
something no I was not that was never my
intention I was gonna explain actually
everything oh well yeah but there you go
maybe that's somewhere where your
reputation hurt you I thought you were
too volatile to let into the studio
[Music]
but here we are yeah I can see yeah
Lunchables
we're eating Lunchables together that's
real friendship right there boy
and get all tough because he does these
videos where he goes to like his haters
house come outside fight me [__]
that's actually kind of funny though
like because he wouldn't do anything
because you're just like filming him
doing that and then you're just like
okay of course he's not gonna do
anything but he's awful I mean he's also
just like gonna be irrelevant a year so
like what's the point that dude that
proved not to be true yes
at least we're still doing it you're
getting more views than her
doesn't she have a kid
or was that was that a fake thing was
that no she actually did having a real
baby oh man
there's a real baby with a real name
it came out of a real
oh
yeah moving on
do you need to come and go but I like
that's bad conversation
no it's okay to have entertainment
no that's like entertainment it's not
like I'm wishing manifestation oh maybe
he's onto better things after that Tick
Tock maybe he's gonna become a doctor or
something you know that's all he's gonna
become a doctor never know I'm
manifesting that for him maybe it's best
maybe a dentist he needs to be on social
media but maybe he'll succeed somewhere
else in life all right enough about
Bryce Hall [__] him let's talk about
[__]
well it's pretty mean-spirited no it was
it was funny okay you find me for that
yeah no I take it back I was never even
mad watching those clips I thought I
thought it was funny you want to crank
this Master Cheese a little bit
thanks man it means a lot smashing the
cheese
as everybody knows the time I was saying
smashing this the Lunchable cheese kit
I don't think so
[Music]
a little stinky actually
uh squashed I'll tell you what brother
if I went to high school with you I
would eat lunch with you really in the
stall or like at a table I'll speed in
the skull next year that'd be fire yeah
we probably get our ass beat for taking
up the Stalls all but it could have been
like uh you know a lot of people like to
make fun of me for that like eating in
the stall but it's like two killing two
birds with one stone did you [__] and
eat oh like sometimes I would like be
using the bathroom I would sit on it
huge [__] pants down huge [__] and sit
on it and eat your lunch yeah well not
not [__] sometimes he's sitting down
yeah I'd like pee sometimes you know
that's fire bro yeah like shooting
that's a little gross just for the smell
but come on you took a dump at least
once okay it was maybe one yeah once or
twice come on you're there
everyone at chat is agreeing that
everybody would be eating oh people are
saying they did the same thing eating in
the stall that was a thing look at us
guys you know when I moved to Florida
you did that before yeah you wait in the
stall when I first when I first moved to
Florida yeah oh that's so that's like
the saddest thing I've ever heard in my
life the spot to go when you just don't
have a place to sit that is so [__]
sad everybody I just strictly remember
from my high school experience like the
anxiety that I would get just walking
into the launching the lunchroom and not
knowing where the hell I'm sitting oh
yeah at a new school too that is well
mine was a school I went to did in the
entire four years but like
but like yeah I like same same type of
feeling God damn bro
if you guys are in high school go during
lunch go check the stock idea in there
and be like yo I want to eat I want I
know what you're doing in there get out
you're eating lunch come hang out with
me bully doesn't need to being your
friend or just like just to like break
the
the simulation just sit at the popular
kid stable see what happens
right just take take the popular kids
table for yourself
um
and say you guys aren't allowed to sit
at my table
do this and then just walk up to him go
like that yeah and then do we bring the
do we wear
bring them bring them cat food I was
gonna do like a no yeah let's not go
there let's not go there wait what I was
gonna make a no did you did you show
Bryce that button right there
I wasn't I was gonna like you've used a
euphemism for it
I was just gonna say and if the popular
kids give you trouble just let them know
that us crazy kids don't [__] around
these days okay maybe maybe not the joke
to make yeah not the yeah exactly
yeah that's why I didn't make it
you know
I'm glad you explained it so I at least
understood the context right I prefer
really not to
not to speak if I speak I am in in big
trouble I'm sorry I'm eating this this
thing is [__] amazing the bread is
like it's spiced it's like crispy with
like it's better than a cracker mmm
Jay Rod
you want a Lunchable j-rod
I'll join I'll join the party J rod do
you maybe one of these things these
things you know what I'd like better
than uh than a Lunchable though is
another blackout
really you've been trash
no no no you want mine right no you
finish it no I'm not gonna I mean I'm
not I'll drink yours if you don't want
it let me finish come get it I just had
one sip it's all you
know
see an alcoholic
um yeah a little bit
thanks
that's all you brother hit that that's
good [__] that's a good flavor Chet is
saying yeah I'll send you a box even
though you don't drink I'll send you
like a box I do drink just I'm not like
a regular Drinker what they be Chad is
saying team Bryce on God team Bryce on
God like like the paparazzi did you ever
see that clipartana Hannah did you a lot
of I feel like she did a good thing for
you there yeah that became a thing that
became I mean like Maya Henry Liam
Liam Payne's ex-fiance made a video
basically saying we teamed Bryce on God
oh it was her who started it
if I can I mean you know I'm right there
Jay Roy I'm everywhere
you know uh tan is a friend of the show
now we love Tana
Tana's been doing great I'm glad he's
like happy for her he's awesome man she
was she was going down like a crazy path
I'm like actually glad she she
completely cleaned up her act she has a
crazy story too her life story is why oh
yeah
I didn't know about all that you got are
you have a history with her you guys
hooking up at one point yeah like when
we were not hooking up it was like a
one-time thing you guys hooked up once
yeah and we realized quite fast that
that is just not the mid-coital or after
coital
um after coital after I must say that
I've had some post-coital regrets
post-coil regrets about that post-coil
regrets and then we did like the roast
of Bryce Hall like that thing with Jason
Nash okay and she like brings it back up
to the surface oh no
people people just
I just want people to like forget about
it yeah was it that embarrass what was
so embarrassing about it it was just
like the things that we did
she sucked your toes why is that
embarrassing for you it's just like did
you ask her too no so she sucked your
toes Tana I'm gonna I'm gonna air you
out again did you like it
um it's okay I actually wouldn't say
that I liked it
you wouldn't say you didn't like it it
tickled and it wasn't putting me in in
like a sexual mood it didn't turn you on
no it was more like that tickles stuff
so she started as she said maybe uh did
you put a finger in your butt
he tried she did she did try and you
shot it down
you ever let anyone put a finger in your
butt maybe if you guys were closer yeah
you'd be cool with that you're gay
[Laughter]
oh [__] it's just you guys weren't close
enough
that was like the that was before I've
done anything freaky okay
you were it was stalking that was
basically like a version at the time
okay so
that was like the weirdest sex I've ever
had
and Taylor it's like Tana Mojo at the
time it was like oh my God it's Tana
Mojo right so I was like oh I'm in bed
with him let's see like what this is
about
and she tries to put a finger in my butt
I was like ah okay
you all look gay
that's what my head that's what my
headspace was thinking holy [__] that's
oh that's funny though right oh you both
have you guys both have alcohols about
getting [__] up that maybe possibly
dying of alcohol poisoning or is it
dizzy she has dizzy oh yeah she does
have dizzy and you have blackout yeah we
need to do a collab if you guys drink
together you're definitely be having
some people dying for sure oh man me and
tana have some crazy stories of drinking
um so we're oh yeah so squashing the
beef there was that moment uh which we
uh put behind us and then you came after
me on Twitter I did which is so at least
we're like hold no I hold no ill will
for these in fact at all yo H3 I think
you should worry about the fat lawsuit
triller gave you instead of talking [__]
about me you old [__] where you and Ryan
already dogs at this point
so he was probably talking to you about
I was suing my ass that's awesome
bro what does he say about me I gotta
know
he doesn't talk about you
please he's it's all he thinks about I
know what'd you think like you're just
like we're sitting down talking business
by the way Ethan sucks
actually you know what to be fair you
said you didn't know anything about it
but I know that man thinks about me all
day you know he spends all day in the
Wikipedia history about it when when
this was all going on right
um and then sorry for calling you old by
the way it's you know what I get it a
lot
you know old man now I'm getting up
there too so it's like no you're such a
young buck bro I'm I'm 37 does that
shock you
I wouldn't have guessed that what would
you have guessed older no I would I
would have probably like because I think
everyone on social media is a roundish
the same age what would you have got I
thought you were 30.
that's nice though because I'm old as
[__]
I wouldn't have guessed I'm just like
generic middle-aged looking maybe
there's 30 middle-aged
not quite no 40. I'm turning 25 right
next year which is crazy
30s wild once you get 30 you just kind
of like get older and older and you're
like what the [__] bro like imma be 38
in June
and there's you have like j-rod Jared's
older than me how old are you j-rod I'm
two or two two days older than rice old
[__] idiots
hey Jared let me see you hit that
Lunchable well no I had a cheese stick
because you guys ran out so I ate the
cheese stick already and now I'm
finished oh we ran out of Lunchables no
it's fine this is sorry bro oh give him
a steak we gotta drink a blackout
instead we want the steak steak I don't
know he's not getting the steak oh no
you eat raw meat j-rod
uh
no no no I'm gonna do for that I like
that little head tilt that was pretty
it's pretty nice yeah but uh you said uh
I don't get why these grandpas and
grandmas always critique 17 to 21 year
old kids as if they weren't [__] up
out of their age you know what that's a
good point
I did I did make a valid point there to
be fair I think you're right I think
sometimes it's easy for us to be super
critical
on social media who are very young
and when I was that age I was a [__] I
was just a big old idiot piece of [__]
like [__] you sorry there there's things
called phones that document [__] now
instead of the Rocks he used to
communicate yes I do know I uh lived
during the time of the dinosaurs
you guys had the rocks and you guys were
just communicating through the Rocks we
had we had just discovered fire it was
tough back then and we were cold all the
time
how how was it during the black and
white times like because it used to be
like black and white the world right
sucks dude oh yeah the whole world was
black and white was weird
saw in some pictures it was pretty crazy
um
I forgive you you know these were these
weren't even that bad it was kind of
funny I don't think you were trying to
be super mean no yeah so there it is you
know I'm just I'm gonna squish it
but I do think you made a good point
it's easy for for my old ass to look at
you and be like oh what a dumbass
[Music]
man these these never get easy these
never get easy what do you want
I think we gotta we gotta swash a new
one well we do we usually squash the
same one
we should take them out
undo it a little bit yeah
[Music]
that's it
smells like cheese yeah
geez
is that the cheese that smells like that
all right we're getting a good squash
here boy oh yeah
[Applause]
that's that's all hydraulic pressure
[Music]
that's it that's a magical moment
that's love
you know what's funny
[Music]
this is a theory we have what so there's
a Wikipedia editor named thrust
I have no association with him but he's
very passionate about maintaining Ryan
Kavanaugh's Wikipedia page
and thank you he has a history of
keeping the controversial things and
questioning the good things this throws
guy not a fan of cavcv uh is what I'm
saying and so kavkav has been desperate
to I this is all Theory to find out who
thrust was
and uh well we know that because he even
messaged you love right and was like are
you thrust yeah he did on LinkedIn on
LinkedIn so somehow I found my old
LinkedIn
and so the funniest example of this is
we found
show me the Shrek form one this is it I
promise I'm not going to keep going but
the Shrek form one's so funny
he sent this to love uh
just to this is our this is just
supporting our theory he said nice to
meet you nice to finally meet find you
perhaps we should talk it's just love
he's just one of our guys I think he
thought he was thrust do you guys have
the Shrek one hey hey what's up Ryan how
can I help you yeah it's fair and so um
there's a Shrek form he found a user
called thrust
here I found it
he went to the depths of the internet
and I'm assuming it's him I don't know
for sure but so here's thrust on Shrek
Wikipedia
and he says Found You The username found
you 35 pleasure to finally meet the
mighty thrust put Pokey around here
somewhere foreign
Forum Shrek Wiki
he says hi throws pleasure to finally
meet you you've been a very busy boy
maybe we should talk sooner than later
found you 35.
is that
who is that I make a in my opinion that
educated ghosts guess that it's Ryan uh
because it's got the similar kind of
writing that What Love Got I mean it's
kind of it's kind of funny his username
found you 35 oh it is funny but he was
trying to find thrust on goddamn Shrek
forms
awesome
yeah but that's that too much wine sorry
yeah it's okay Ryan
it gets the best of all of us
yeah but uh
yeah he's not me he's not good at making
fake names that's for sure
so I mean in short I think um
we've talked about a lot
you know
we've seen it all we've talked about it
all I'm glad we talked what's your
dreams you got dreams what's your big
goals coming up here I just
um I just want to be in the
entertainment space for a very long time
I wanna
I definitely am open to like any form of
entertainment besides music
Cab's trying to put you in movies right
I did do a movie with 50 Cent and that's
in post-production now yeah were you a
main character oh wow what was the
shooting schedule for that like oh dude
shooting schedules are so [__] it was
like uh waking up at 3 A.M certain days
getting on set at four oh wow and then
half of the other times when we're doing
daytime shots or nighttime shots it's
like you don't get on set until like 9
00 p.m and you're there till like 4am oh
it was a horror movie thing right
were you the Baddie or the goodie I mean
it's like there's like a mix it's like a
horror comedy uh suspense like
everything but oh yes skill uh
skill house yeah here it is
and you're like a star are you the main
character yeah oh that's dub it's
actually a pretty um pretty sick concept
it's uh all the shittiest social media
kids like the biggest ones on the
internet they all get kidnapped and then
tortured in a soul-like way because the
the writers of Saul wrote it oh really
yeah that's pretty good pedigree yeah so
it's like you hate these social media
influencers so much you learn to hate
them and then uh they get tortured do
you know where it's going is it going to
theaters or it's going in theaters wow
yeah that's pretty exciting yeah no it
is it is sick uh I definitely want to
venture more into like the comedy space
less horror or comedy horror comedy
horror is okay like this was okay uh but
definitely want to do uh
more comical stuff I got you your your
passion's more on Comedy yeah yeah I
like making people laugh not scared
right
sometimes I do both unintentionally
j-rod
um
do you know when it's when is it coming
out I'm actually I'd love to watch it
yeah you should you should actually come
to the premiere holy [__] that would be
the mean
that would be insane if you came to the
premiere I could get all of you guys
tickets oh hell yeah I actually would
like oh God that'd be so weird and wild
that'd be the real comedy horror right
there oh that is the horror that's our
group that's our skill house cavcraft's
gonna walk the doors and burn us from
the outside he's gonna lock it for you
know what I mean that is
hilarious yeah like a goddamn the
vampires but no it is it's coming out uh
at the end of this year it's looking
like that's that's awesome maybe near
Halloween that's super exciting I'm very
happy for you
most capcab on set is he hands on kind
of producer he was very Hands-On and um
I know you have your beef with Kavanaugh
but like this guy knows how to make
movies well that's his that's his this
guy like has been non-stop grinding this
thing that's his background right yeah I
mean he did bankrupt his he's making but
the bankrupt there I have nothing I have
no idea about anything about that but
this guy knows how to make a good movie
he has you've seen his movies his movies
he's made great movies I won't take that
away from him
he's made great movies movies I love
yeah he knows how to put on yeah I'll
say something nice about Kavanaugh
but he he made like I think genuinely
what happened is he made so many flops
in a road that he went banking so so the
flops
um he has never made a movie that didn't
make more money than he spent on it well
that's not true because he went bankrupt
well I think there was other reasons why
he went bankrupt he was in debt like 1.3
million or billion dollars
I think he's blowing smoke up your ass
with that one if I'm being fair because
I complimented him now I gotta pull it
back down to reality a little bit
but I'm excited for you man that's
that's really cool Ryan Cavanaugh is a
force of nature
Harvey vouchers
oh [__] and then let's see you've got uh
goddy you and him are really tight
you've got this movie coming up
we do a lot of business together it's
good
oh you're also doing a dog food [__]
with him and a few other celebs yeah um
it's a charity
oh it's not even a business it's just
charity well it is a business it so like
every single time you purchase something
from their website it saves a dog to
shelter really yeah it's actually like a
really good concept it's funny it has a
Snoop Dogg yeah called dog for dog
is that crazy is that thing it's like a
dog food thing or products dog for dog
it has it has like everything that like
a dog needs you have a dog
um no but there's a dog in my house
[Music]
not it's like the family dog but family
dog yeah I love dogs I I literally grew
up with dogs my entire life so I mean
uh let's see Bryce's dog house it's a
dog for dog brycesdoghouse.com yeah you
just get like uh
I think it's like 40 off okay let's
promote dogs for dogs Ryan Cavanaugh eat
your heart out
but I bet he never thought you see me
promoting one of his products
dog for dog prices dogcast.com
yeah and every single uh purchase even
if it's like a a five dollar purchase on
the website
it feeds a dog in a shelter they they're
um they're doing a show around it too oh
peanut butter they're revamping like
massive shelters like just spending a
bunch of money in these shelters uh
renovating them and then saving the dogs
it's really it's a really beautiful
project to be honest Chad thinks you're
getting dropped I hope not yo if they
drop you talk to me I'll help you out
I [__] ruined your whole life bro
that'd suck
nah they're good you know what I mean it
happens listen he can let's we'll talk
we'll work it out you know I'll make
them I'll put you in a movie and yeah
you said some band things but you've
also said some good things about himself
dog for dog yeah he's made great movies
he's made great movies in fact here I'll
pull up his best films we could be like
yo cap we said nice things look look at
this look at this look these are these
are Ryan Kavanaugh movies
here Ryan cabin on Rotten Tomatoes
see
oh [__] there's a lot of
Flats how do we do it from the um
how do we do it from the like best
down because there's a lot of space yeah
I actually don't know
there's actually
more splats
then greed I mean
like let's see this one did pretty good
he did The Social Network that was a
that didn't that win like an awards yeah
that one was recent Oculus how big of
knights
I love that movie Oculus is massive
um 21 and over that was a good movie I
don't know why that got such a shitty
review really bad reviews
27 that's brutal did you like that man
do you know what movie that is I didn't
see it's the the Blackjack movie okay
movie 43 have you seen that wrong they
got four percent Rosie dog [__] movie
that movie was so [__] up funny though
like it's like very 2011 humor Bryce but
the humor in that movie was so funny
it's like just so [__] you something
after hearing you say how funny this
movie is and Ryan Cavanaugh be involved
are you afraid that you're gonna end up
is there a possibility that potentially
you get a four percent I think uh
there's gonna be a lot of hate obviously
I mean like look at what Addison Ray's
movie did I mean she I thought that her
performance was pretty good but they
there there were some like oh that she's
all that one yeah yeah I watched that
yeah there was like yeah her performance
was great but because she was Addison
Ray they're like oh [__] this Tick Tock
or what stay in your lane blah blah
right um but it was still the number one
movie on Netflix oh it was yeah good for
her so I mean he's actually killing it
man yeah like
I think there's gonna be a lot of hate
when they see me on the big screen but
it's like it's gonna get reviews and
that's all that really matters well I
hope well the bet the the bar is low for
for Kev Cav and these kind of teen
Thrillers if it gets over four percent
yeah then that's progress yeah like four
four let's go let's aim for five let's
say for the seven paranoia seventh good
I'm picking seven
Haywire uh did pretty good yeah it's
just a limitless that one that was
actually [__] I like the bomb moving
yeah that was a good movie Take Me Home
Tonight one of my favorite fighter that
one that's an award winner yeah okay
that wasn't that best picture of the
year yeah there you go cavcap you know
what you're doing he had some pretty
good ones catfish
yeah this is all
these are all his films boy the
Zombieland was so good I loved the
zombie okay see he's got some great ones
under his belt
and a lot of shitty ones
that one but we're not talking about
those
oh his average score is 58 which is
pretty good that's not that bad yeah
that's actually pretty good it's a it's
like an f plus
I mean 58 but like look at I bet look up
any other producer I bet it's like okay
fair enough let's do that let's go
Steven Spiel you sure you wanna do
Stephen uh actually no all right let's
do uh what about like uh well who's the
the Tommy wise oh maybe who's the
Transformers guy Michael Bay yeah he
makes [__] he makes a lot of
[Music]
go down to his average
oh he doesn't even have a name hold on
let me do
Harvey actually has a really good record
yeah I think that dude made Banger after
Banger I don't think that's the average
Ethan that was the that was a TV shows
rating for so wait does it do an average
for us does it oh [__] let me go back
down to the bottom oh he made a TV show
oh
so can we crunch the average I'd like to
do that for him if we can
probably lower if I had to guess based
on just scanning this
you know
movie 43 I do remember seeing trailers
for this that movie was so funny
star-studded though bro now like if it's
like so [__] up like you uh Hugh
Jackman had a ball sack on his chin what
they have such famous people in this
yeah
so funny Richard Gere that's him right
this kid that this kid Halle Berry right
there
um who's that chick on the left I know
her at the bottom left
he's uh
she was in that movie with Nicolas Cage
okay Grace Moretz
or she's like a badass yeah you're
talking about Kick-Ass it was a Chloe
Moretz
yeah but uh you know what I'm happy that
uh
that you guys have a great partnership I
think that's great that you somehow got
hooked up with them especially Brad
seems to be coming through so lots of
love for Brad Brad's doing great yeah
first first first kid I'm already a
handful like and he's he's actually like
doing great for me appreciate it that's
awesome good for you guys
um
yeah so anyway I'm happy for you man
you're doing good just stay just keep it
straight and narrow bro please and
therapy is good I think you'll you'll
maybe find because the court ordered
therapy they're not gonna be the the
right therapist may be the best for me
you've there's some really good ones out
there you know what I mean
but I'm glad you're doing the anger
stuff too that's good I'm happy you seem
to be working on yourself in a good
place I'm sorry for you know I've I've
spin a douche too man no no I have been
no it's like
it was like the thing to do it's
completely acceptable and this music is
perfect for this it is this is the
touching moments music I think I think
it was just like
it was the time Bryce Hall was the most
hated guy on the internet it was funny
to make fun of me right we're changing
that yeah you're not anymore I'm not
that hated anymore I still kind of hate
it but you know it's residual hey
it is not it's not your fault your fault
you've seen that movie no I have not
really it's not your fault
analogous to Bryce perhaps he like you
didn't believe in therapy then he met
Robin Williams his therapist who changed
his life and he said this famously to
him
it's not your fault and in this analogy
I am Robin Williams
it's not your fault thank you yeah no
I'm kidding anyway dude it was nice to
thanks for coming in it was really fun I
hope I didn't get you into trouble oh no
you don't yeah but legitimately if
there's a if there's a bridge here let's
you know if you want to be a peacekeeper
you just text me and we'll see we'll see
if 100 but bro maybe I'll get Ryan on
here for you that'd be weird that'd be
weird and wild that'd be a crazy podcast
though
I wonder how that would go
boy but I'll tell you I never seen
someone disappointed as I saw Brad when
he saw me like my mom has never looked
at me with such disappointed he's just
like oh you're doing this
no but he's a good guy thanks bro I
really hope you didn't get in trouble
but thanks guys everyone for watching I
had a great time a great time with the
Bryce he's up to all kinds of things
mostly on Snapchat is where it's
happening but we're all looking forward
to your movie I think all the H3 Nations
gonna be tuning in oh dude I can't wait
I just can't wait to hear the reviews
I'm we're on your side bro that's it
you're a friend of the show now
scale house is the movie everybody get
buy can we buy tickets now uh not yet
um I think in the next like three weeks
you can I can seriously buy tickets
ready for a movie that comes out at the
end of the year yeah well it's it's like
uh so we're we're releasing
um like cards and merchandise okay that
have like your your ticket so if you buy
it okay uh there's a scanner that it
represents your ticket but you can go to
any theater with that really yeah it'll
be your ticket all right I'm gonna March
up I have this it's called I want to
support you but at the same time I'm
supporting Ryan it's such a weird
conflict event I'll send you it so you
don't have to purchase oh that's what's
up so I'll promote the movie for you
yeah thanks bro
all right guys it's been Bryce Hall he's
the man he's a good guy he's reformed we
love him he's a friend of the show thank
you for being here thank you so much for
having me man all right guys we'll see
you uh tomorrow bright and early for
leftovers with Hassan
tell him I came on I want to hear his
reaction I'll be listening I will well I
try to get him to come today but
but he didn't yeah he's he's like a he's
a busy guy yeah he's just streaming he's
like I gotta stream bro
all right guys we'll see you tomorrow
thank you all so much thank you Bryce
thank you too
what's happening uh Jay broad uh he
forgot my name James he's only been
saying it the entire time
you owe me an expensive lunchable just
so you know we do I do all right I'm so
sorry thanks for giving me a mic
absolutely
all right thanks man see you tomorrow
thanks guys